liebe kolleginnen und kollegen herzlich
willkommen in der bundespressekonferenz
zur aktuellen lage heute an einem
donnerstag begrüße ich den
bundesminister für gesundheit ganz
sparen nicht größer professor oder
wieder die präsidenten des robert koch
institutes und ich begrüße kabeln lange
intensivpfleger seien sie uns herzlich
willkommen lassen sie mich aufgrund der
tatsache dass ja heute wieder eine
intensive live berichterstattung haben
kurz sagen die bundespressekonferenz ist
ein verein der von journalistinnen und
journalisten wir sind
regierungsunabhängig und wir laden hier
in diese pressekonferenz mit der von der
bundes der bundesregierung oder spreche
spreche die bundesregierung ein um
unsere fragen zu beantworten so auch
heute auf dem fernsehsender phoenix für
das ein gebärdendolmetscher umgeben
dafür danken wir sehr herzlich
ja macht es immer minister ja das ist ja
vielen danke fällt auf meine damen und
herren wir sind tatsächlich heute am
donnerstag da weil ich morgen in hamburg
unter anderem im zentrum sein werde was
das größte im zentrum deutschlands ist
das bringt mir bringt mich auch gleich
zum thema wir haben zwar noch nicht ich
rechne jetzt minütlich damit die zahlen
von gestern aber insgesamt eher in den
letzten tagen gesehen eine deutliche
steigerung bei den impfungen vor vier
monaten am 27 dezember wurde zum ersten
mal jemand in deutschland geimpft
mittlerweile sind es über 20 millionen
menschen die eine erste impfung haben in
deutschland erhalten können gegen kuwait
und die zahl steigt weiter ständig und
seitdem wir die arztpraxen einbezogen
haben und sehr die voraussetzungen der
impfstoff zur verfügung haben sehen wir
jetzt auch und ich gehe davon aus auch
in dieser woche immer mal wieder auch
neue tages rekorde das sind gute
nachrichten auch bei aller kritik an dem
erwarteten langsamen start im ersten
quartal wir schaffen nämlich mit diesen
impfungen die voraussetzungen dafür dass
wir mehr alltag wieder möglich machen
können schritt für schritt
gleichzeitig sehen wir dass der steile
anstieg der infektionszahlen hat vorerst
gebremst werden können
sie scheinen sich die infektionszahlen
erfolgen niveau zu stabilisieren den
letzten zwei tagen sehen wir sogar
das momentaufnahmen oder ein trend auch
zurückzugehen das reicht aber leider
noch nicht denn die zahlen insgesamt
sind noch zu hoch das zeigt auch der
blick auf die intensivstationen die sind
weiterhin in zu vielen städten in zu
vielen regionen zufolge mit 19 patienten
müssen teilweise verlegt werden
ärzte und pflegekräfte arbeiten seit
monaten spätestens seit beginn der
zweiten welle am anschlag in vielen
intensivstation und deswegen bin ich
dankbar dass ricardo lange heute auch
mit dabei ist als intensivpfleger
vielleicht auch kurz zur herleitung habe
ja ein letzter bundespressekonferenz
auch gesagt mit handys und anderen ein
gespräch führen zu wollen das habe ich
ja mit herrn liefert dann auch sogar
dokumentiert gemacht ich bin anderer
meinung aber umso wichtiger ist es dass
man miteinander redet und übrigens
deswegen ist es auch völlig okay ob ich
jetzt die meinung teile oder den stil
das eben auch kritik geäußert wird die
männer im gespräch miteinander ist und
ricardo lange hat daraufhin gesagt
der andere aspekt muss aber eben auch
eine rolle spielen nämlich die situation
auf den intensivstationen dann habe ich
gesagt das wäre doch heute eine gute
gelegenheit auch den aspekt doch mal mit
in den mittelpunkt zu rücken
deshalb ist ihm klar die zahlen müssen
nicht nur stagnieren sie müssen runter
weiter runter so schützen wir leben so
schützen wir aber eben vor allem auch
unser gesundheitssystem vor überlastung
und dass die zahlen runter gehen und
kommen weiter ist die voraussetzung
dafür dass wir dann sicher öffnen können
und auch sicher lockern können das ist
die voraussetzung damit wir das sicher
tun können in den schulen in den
kindertagesstätten für die
verkäuferinnen und verkäufer im
einzelhandel für treffen mit freunden
und familien für alle bereiche um die es
dann beim öffnen auch geht nach monaten
des verzichts gibt der fortschritt beim
impfen hoffnung verbesserungen ist
spürbar in sich der juni ich weiß in der
zeit wie dieser ist jeder tag lang und
jede woche lang aber der juni ist nicht
mehr weit weg warum der juni wir gehen
stand heute davon aus dass wir
spätestens im juni die impf
priorisierung
aufheben können will aber noch mal
ausdrücklich sagen sie hat sehr viel
sinn gemacht und macht es bis heute
wir haben menschen leben geschützt das
ist keine bürokratie das ist schutz von
menschenleben
dass wir zuerst die über 80-jährigen die
über 70-jährigen geimpft haben die
pflege heimbewohnerinnen und -bewohner
und diejenigen die sich um sie kümmern
weil dort eben auch das risiko am
höchsten war und ich finde es weiterhin
jeden tag beeindruckend zu sehen auch
bei den infektionszahlen bei den über
80-jährigen wie sehr das impfen dort
einen positiven unterschied macht
und jetzt in der so genannten pro gruppe
3 sind die über 60 jährigen sind aber
eben auch viele berufsgruppen
verkäuferinnen und verkäufer busfahrer
justizbeamte lehrerinnen und lehrer
dabei die keinen home office machen
können die sich nicht immer aussuchen
können wem sie wie begegnen oder
begegnen müssen auch dann mit
entsprechender nicht immer einhaltung
von regeln und die jetzt seit vier
monaten auf ihre impfung warten und ich
finde sie sollten jetzt und müssen jetzt
zuerst im mai auch das impfangebot
bekommen bevor wir dann im juni werden
allen ein angebot machen können das
heißt aber nicht ich sage es noch einmal
war es wichtig ist fürs
erwartungsmanagement dass dann alle
gleich innerhalb von 12 wochen dran sind
wartezeiten wird es weiterhin geben bis
in den sommer hinein
auch die betriebsärztin und
betriebsärzte werden dann im juni
regelhaft mitmachen können
gleichwohl und nachvollziehbarer weise
gibt es eine debatte auch darüber
diskutieren wer schon länger
wie ist es mit den rechten oder
möglichkeiten von menschen mit
vollständigen impfschutz und da finde
ich ganz wichtig drei bereiche zu
unterscheiden schon nach ostern haben
wir auch auf basis von einer
einschätzung des robert-koch-instituts
gesagt das getestete und geimpfte
geimpfte und aktuell getestete
gleichgestellt werden können bei vielen
bereichen das ist auch relativ leicht
umzusetzen viele länder haben das
richtigerweise schon in ihren
landesverordnung umgesetzt wir sind
gerade dabei das in der einreise
verordnung umzusetzen wo es ja auch
tests pflichten gibt
das ist ein bereich wie gesagt wo das
gleichstellen das möglich machen dass
das geimpft sein
unterschied macht vergleichsweise
einfach ist weil wir eben wissen
bei vollständig geimpften ist das
infektionsrisiko sogar noch geringer als
bei tagesaktuell getesteten das robert
koch institut hat im übrigen auch schon
vor zwei wochen etwa die regelungen und
empfehlungen zur kontaktpersonen
angepasst das enge kontaktpersonen die
vollständig geimpft sind nicht mehr in
quarantäne müssen sind die bereiche die
leicht umzusetzen sind oder schon
umgesetzt worden ist schwieriger auch
rechtlich in der abwägung ist die frage
was ist mit beschränkung ausgangs
beschränkung kontakt beschränkungen also
das einschränken von freiheitsrechten
wie es durch landesregelung aber jetzt
eben auch durch die bundes notbremse
erfolgt ist kann soll muss man dort
einen unterschied machen zwischen
vollständig geimpften und noch nicht
vollständig geimpften und das ist eine
debatte wie wir in den letzten tagen
merken
in der phase jetzt im übergang wo eben
noch nicht so viele haben vollständig
geimpft sein können viele jetzt seit
monaten auch auf ihre impfung warten und
für andere zurückgetreten sind und
gleichzeitig natürlich die die geimpft
sind sagen aber wenn ich kein risiko
mehr bin dann geht auch die
einschränkung meiner freiheit nicht dass
in einen guten ausgleich zu bringen und
dann natürlich einen sehr starken
gewichtung auch für freiheitsrechte
darum geht es jetzt in der
gesellschaftlichen aber auch in der
politischen debatte
und deswegen ist es gut wenn jetzt nicht
nur die bundesregierung sondern auch
bundestag und bundesrat hier an dieser
entscheidung beteiligt sind
es ist ja die frage ob es schneller
gehen kann als der 28
theoretisch kann es das praktisch im
zweifel auch wichtig ist jetzt erst mal
dass wir einen entwurf erarbeiten gehe
ich davon aus dass wir den in der
nächsten woche haben seitens der
bundesregierung und dass wir ihn dann
schon frühzeitig mit bundestag und
bundesrat so abstimmen dass dann das
verfahren auch zügig gehen kann
spätester bundesrat aber ist der 28 ein
letztes wenn sie gestatten zu indien
wir sehen gerade weltweit dass es keinen
grund gibt dieses virus zu unterschätzen
und wir sehen es gerade besonders
schmerzhaft und leid
in indien wir sehen dort im grunde ein
worst case szenario eine virusvariante
oder mehrere die sich teilweise völlig
ungebremst in einer bevölkerung
ausbreiten die viel viel jünger ist im
schnitt als die europäische indien ist
ja von der bevölkerung her auch im
durchschnitt seite viel jünger und damit
eigentlich insgesamt geringeres risiko
für viele und gleichwohl wenn das virus
sich dann völlig ungehemmt ausbreiten
kann eben doch mit viel leid verbunden
und mit bildern die glaube ich bei uns
allen ein eindruck hinterlassen und ja
wir haben ein anderes gesundheitssystem
und ja wir haben auch eine chance auf
bessere grund gesundheit bei uns hier in
deutschland und gleichwohl sieht man
eben in brasilien wie in indien sehr
leidvoll was dieses virus anrichten kann
wenn man es nicht unter kontrolle bringt
deswegen haben wir schlüsse daraus
gezogen um uns selbst zu schützen indem
wir die einreise aus diesem virus
varianten gebiet eingeschränkt haben im
moment nur deutsche und menschen mit
wohnsitz in deutschland zurück oder
einreisen können
nach deutschland bei den entsprechenden
flügen flügen dass es quarantäne
erfordernisse test erfordernisse gibt
dass der eine teil der gleichzeitig aber
auch helfen und helfen wollen als
bundesregierung zum hilfspaket der
bundesregierung trägt das
bundesministerium für gesundheit waren
im wert von etwa 50 millionen euro bei
das sind 120 beatmungsgeräte das sind
medikamente ramsey wir insbesondere und
schutzmasken die wir auf vorrat haben
und die helfen sollen die not in indien
zu lindern und in guter bewährter
zusammenarbeit mit den kollegen im
verteidigungsministerium und der
luftwaffe werden diese dinge nun zügig
auch nach indien ausgeflogen also
zusammengefasst es gibt hoffnung
es gibt auch viele dinge die zuversicht
geben können aber es gibt noch keine
entwarnung in dieser phase der pandemie
und wir dürfen jetzt die letzten
schritte zumindest stand heute letzten
schritte eben auch nicht verstolpern
heisst also jetzt wenn wir die ersten
zwei drei tage eine gute entwicklung
sehen gleich das gefühl
ok sondern es geht darum die zahlen
weiter runter zu bringen und zum zweiten
gerade beim öffnen bei einem höheren
grad von impfungen die richtige
geschwindigkeit beim öffnen zu finden
länder die israel und das vereinigte
königreich haben uns gezeigt wie wichtig
das ist ich denke wenn wir diese
erfahrungen zusammen bringen dann werden
wir auch diesen teil
zusammen schaffen vielen dank an
minister
herr professor und tag meine damen und
herren die panini meine damen und kann
ist leider noch nicht vorbei sie ist
weder in deutschland vorbei noch in
europa noch weltweit innerhalb einer
woche sind weltweit die pfalz die
weltweit die fallzahlen um mehr als 24
prozent angestiegen und das geschehen
ist dabei sehr unterschiedlich besonders
schwer betroffen tatsächlich zurzeit
asien und vor allem in den minister
hatte das angesprochen
hier könnte auch die variante 1 617 eine
rolle spielen aber das ist im moment
noch nicht eindeutig zu beurteilen es
gibt international auch gute nachrichten
in ländern in denen zuerst strenge
maßnahmen getroffen wurden und zwar
wirklich strenge harte lockdown und erst
dann gelockert wurde als ein großteil
der bevölkerung einmal geimpft war sind
die sieben tages inzidenz in
vergleichsweise gering
in großbritannien beispielsweise liegt
sie jetzt bei etwa 25 und in israel
bei etwa 12 aber ich möchte zwei dinge
ganz klar sagen erstens die pandemie
wird erst dann unter kontrolle sein wenn
sie in allen teilen der welt unter
kontrolle ist
denn das virus kennt keine landesgrenzen
zweitens die infektion schutzmaßnahmen
und impfungen ja sie weisen uns den weg
aus der pandemie es ist deshalb ganz
entscheidend dass impfstoffe weltweit
auch gleich verteilt werden aber sind
eben beides die infektion
schutzmaßnahmen plus impfung nichts
ersetzt das andere zu zahlen es gibt
einen satz den epidemiologen seit beginn
dieser pandemie immer wiederholen
wir sind nur sicher wenn alle sicher
sind und das muss uns allen einfach klar
ich bitte sie das auch kontinuierlich im
kopf zu behalten schon zur situation in
deutschland die fallzahlen das hatte
sich schon letzte woche angedeutet
steigen im moment nicht mehr rasant an
die bundesweite 7 tages inzidenz pendelt
sich in den letzten zeit so zwischen 150
und 170 1
es ist also gelungen diese dritte welle
abzubremsen
seit ostern hat sich das exponentielle
wachstum der fallzahlen nicht mehr in
dem maße fortgesetzt wie wir das
befürchtet und auch prognostiziert
hatten
und zwar weil die mobilität über ostern
deutlich geringer war aber sehr
wahrscheinlich auch weil sich noch mehr
menschen an die maßnahmen gehalten haben
noch mehr menschen ihre kontakte
reduziert haben und dem virus damit die
chance genommen haben sich weiter zu
verbreiten
wir sehen also und das sehen wir überall
auf der welt dass das wirkt und das ist
eine gute entwicklung aber ich möchte
mich hier deshalb wie so oft wirklich
bei allen bedanken die das tun die dazu
beitragen indem sie selbstverantwortlich
sich aber damit natürlich auch andere
schützen und das ist der entscheidende
aspekt wie wir diese pandemie bewältigen
können für eine entwarnung ist es leider
momentan zu früh die fallzahlen sind
insgesamt nämlich immer noch zu hoch
besonders bei den unter 60-jährigen hier
nehmen die ja sogar zu bei den kindern
sind die zahlen sogar noch einmal
deutlich angestiegen
kinder werden seltener krank ja und auch
deutlich seltener schwer krank aber es
gibt auch erste studien die zeigen dass
es eben auch bei kindern longo witt
geben kann
und hierzu meine damen und herren werde
in den nächsten wochen monaten sicher
noch wissenschaftliche studien mehr
details an den tag bringen und ein
differenzierteres bild aber das nimmt es
doch nicht jetzt schon aus der pflicht
dass wir auch jetzt schon daran denken
und unsere handlungen entsprechend
gestalten dass wir auch dafür sorgen
dass die instanzen runtergehen und damit
auch weniger kinder infiziert werden
kinder tragen auf jeden fall zur
infektionsgeschehen bei das sehen wir
aktuell auch ein entwicklung der
intelligenz in den entsprechenden
altersgruppen und das ist natürlich
besonders hoch wenn dies
besonders so wenn die schulen und kitas
geöffnet sind und besonders dann wenn
die hygiene konzepte eben nicht oder
nicht konsequent umgesetzt werden dann
nehmen natürlich die fallzahlen bei
kindern zu auch auf den
intensivstationen bleibt die situation
angespannt und ich freue mich sehr dass
ricardo lange heute bei uns ist der weiß
wovon ich nur sprechen kann der das
nämlich tagtäglich erlebt und ich danke
ihnen und ihren kollegen und kollegen
für den einsatz die die seit monaten
halten und ich bin ich bin sehr
beeindruckt wie sie das durchstehen
das muss aber nicht so sein wir können
die leute im krankenhaus durchaus
entlasten indem wir für die sinkenden
fallzahlen suchen das ist unser ziel
die zunahme an patienten die
intensivmedizinisch behandelt werden
müssen die hat sich glücklicherweise
auch leicht abgebremst ja aber die
belastung ist natürlich nach wie vor
sehr hoch und denken sie bitte daran
dass auch jüngere menschen
ich sag jetzt unter 65 verleger selber
60 bin bin ich auch bei den jüngeren
ohne vorerkrankungen oder risikofaktoren
auch schwere cupid läufe und verläuft
natürlich entwickeln können auch sie
müssen rechtzeitig behandelt werden und
leider nehmen tatsächlich die
todeszahlen halt dazu und das ist eine
folge der konstant hohen fallzahlen
wir müssen also weiter alles dafür tun
um die fallzahlen zu senken und nur so
können wir auch diejenigen schützen die
eben noch nicht geimpft sind
und nur so können wir kliniken entlassen
schwere verläufe und todesfälle
verhindern und auch langzeitfolgen
verhindern die wir bitte nicht aus dem
auge lassen bei der risikoeinschätzung
studien deuten darauf hin dass viele
infizierte und zwar auch jüngere und
auch patienten mit zunächst milden
verläufen von langzeitfolgen wie
erschöpfung atembeschwerden und
konzentrationsstörungen betroffen sein
können nach den daten die wir zurzeit
haben die sind nicht final könnte das
jeden zehnten treffen
das dürfen wir nicht zulassen meine
damen und herren auch durch impfung wird
das virus übrigens nicht verschwinden
wir wissen dass die impfungen uns eine
grund die miete geben
und das bedeutet dass unser körper das
virus effizient bekämpfen
und wir gar nicht oder weniger krank
werden
aber sie verhindern nicht immer dass
eine infektion mit dem sauerstoff zwei
geschieht das heißt auch bei geimpften
besteht ein restrisiko dass sie sich
infizieren und andere anstecken können
noch ist es nicht soweit sehr bald aber
wenn die meisten älteren und personen
aus risikogruppen geimpft sein und sie
fahren sozusagen gut und sicher
angeschnallt durch diese pandemie
gleichzeitig fehlt den jüngern aber noch
dieser sicherheitsgurt daher sind sie
weiterhin auf verkehrsregeln und
umsichtige verkehrsteilnehmer angewiesen
die dem infektionsgeschehen angepasst
durch die gegend fahren
das sind wir alle lassen sie uns also
weiter solidarisch miteinander sein
geimpften und ungeimpften um diese
dritte welle so gut wie möglich zu
überstehen und zu brechen indem wir uns
und unser persönliches umfeld weiterhin
schützen bewahren wir viele ungeimpfte
davor dass sie sich jetzt noch auf den
letzten metern kurz vor der impfung
infizieren
das kann und das sollte das ziel von uns
allen seinen daumen sollten wir alle
dazu beitragen
vielen dank herr wiedererlangen wetter
sehr guten tag meine damen und herren
bevor ich mit meinen ausführungen
fortfahren möchte ich mich bei ihnen für
meine ungeübte bezüglich
pressekonferenzen dieser art
entschuldigen sollte es also zu kurzen
denkpausen oder anderen versprechen
kommen bittet um nachsicht
ich bin heute hier um über die arbeit
auf den intensivstationen zu sprechen
ich selbst bin intensiv konnten pfleger
angestellt in meinem
zeitarbeitsunternehmen und habe somit
guten einblick in den berliner kliniken
und denke dass ich hier ein gutes abbild
darstellen kann und eines möchte ich mit
einer mit aller klarheit sagen viele
meiner kolleginnen und kollegen arbeiten
seit einem jahr an ihrer
belastungsgrenze und darüber hinaus
viele kollegen haben den beruf schon
verlassen und werden
auch in zukunft weiterhin tun wenn es so
weitergeht und sich für uns nichts
ändert und zu den kollegen möchte ich
nicht nur die erste zählen sondern ganz
insbesondere auch das reinigungspersonal
was ebenfalls in dieser zeit hohen
zusätzlichen belastungen ausgesetzt ist
die pflege arbeitet seit vielen jahren
schon am limit
doch leider hat es bisher in diesem
umfang niemanden interessiert seit der
krone pandemie ist natürlich die
körperliche belastung enorm gestiegen
was zum einen an der schutzausrüstung
liegt die man tagtäglich trägt sie
müssen sich vorstellen
sie arbeiten an ein intensiv bereich und
müssen dort aufgrund des
infektionsschutzgesetzes jahr mit
schutzkleidung arbeiten diese
schutzkleidung ist aus plastik und ist
somit wasserabweisend sie schwitzen
unter der kleidung
sie frieren wenn sie die kleidung
ausziehen weil der ja der casag also die
arbeitskleidung nass ist und sie tragen
außerhalb der zimmerner sp2 maske
durchgängig acht stunden lang erzählen
sie kommen mal zu ihrer pause und können
wir vom pausenbrot abreißen und im
patientenzimmer wo sie teilweise mehrere
stunden verbringen weil eben die
patienten so krank sind das ist eine
permanente anwesenheit am wetter fordert
und sagt tragen sie wie gesagt diese fp3
maske die noch mal deutlich dichter ist
und unter körperlicher anstrengung wie
zb bei bauch lagen die wir ja nun schon
seit fast einem jahr täglich mehrmals
durchführen müssen und das jetzt noch
mal bei dem bauch lagen sind muss man
halt auch wissen dass man dazu immer
fünf leute benötigt vier pflegekräfte
einen arzt das ist nicht nur körperlich
anstrengend diesen patienten im bett zu
drehen sondern es hat auch immer mit
risiken verbunden
sie können sich vorstellen wenn der
datenklau rausrutscht dann hat der
patient aufgrund seiner fehlenden
reserven ein problem und schwebt in
lebensgefahr
das dazu dass dann kommt noch dazu dass
auch die seelische belastung natürlich
deutlich gestiegen ist oder ihr möchte
ich immer zum beispiel dann stellen sie
sich vor sie sind intensiv frank kläger
kommt zum frühdienst und haben geraten
patient aufgenommen erst wach
ansprechbar
scheinbar stabil sie unterhalten sich
reden über familienverhältnisse sprechen
mit ihm und großverfahren sein
es wird alles gut werden herr müller wie
auch immer und gehen nach hause ich
haben feierabend nächsten tag kommen sie
zum frühdienst das bett ist leer
der patient hat die nacht nicht überlebt
weil er sich in der nacht so
verschlechtert hat dass er einfach
verstorben ist und diese situation haben
wir häufig anderes beispiel sie betreuen
eine mutter um die 50 zwei kinder
mehrere wochen leider liegen ja die
kugel patienten eben nicht nur wenige
tage sondern teilweise auch mehrere
wochen bis monate bei uns auf der
intensivstation
monatelang wochen lang kämpfen sie
gemeinsam mit der familie um das leben
dieser patientin die telefonieren
täglich mit den kindern und irgendwann
kommt der tag an dem der arzt die
angehörigen anrufen muss um ihnen
mitzuteilen dass die mutter die nacht
nicht überleben wird
in normalen zeiten haben natürlich immer
mit verstorbenen zu tun
wir werden als intensiv krankenpfleger
immer todkranke menschen betreuen aber
in normalen zeiten sterben die patienten
anders
sie sterben im beisein ihrer familie im
verschlechterung prozess ist die familie
jeden tag da kann den oder die
angehörige die mutter dem vater wem auch
immer anfassen ohne handschuhe ohne
schutzkittel ohne visier und kann diese
mutter diesen vater wochenlang tage lang
begleiten
aufgrund des infektionsschutzgesetzes es
ist jetzt so dass die familie erst
kommen darf wenn sich abzeichnet dass
der patient in kürze versterben wird und
jetzt stellen sie sich vor sie kommen
ins krankenhaus und müssen abschied
nehmen mit mundschutz mit kittel mit
handschuhen
sie haben keinen körperlichen kontakt
und auch wenn die mama noch ansprechbar
sein sollte was in den meisten fällen
leider nicht mehr ist sieht sie sie zum
letzten mal mit maske vermittelt und das
ist das letzte was sie sieht
und dazu kommt dass wir pflegekräfte
wenn die patienten dann leider
verstorben sind eben diese menschen
wieder zum infektionsschutz ins schwarze
plastiksäcke packen müssen
wir legen sie dort hinein und zieht den
reißverschluss und glauben sie mir wenn
ich ihnen sage
macht was mit ein das ist ja nicht nur
einmal nicht zweimal nicht dreimal
sondern bisher unzählige male und da
muss man sich auch als mensch erst mal
dran gewöhnen was hätte auch meiner mama
sein kandidat liegt und es sehe ich
manchmal schon sehr belastend
nun muss ich auch dazu sagen dass ich
als intensiv krankenpfleger generell
wahrscheinlich jeder krankenpfleger
einer gewissen betriebsblindheit
unterliegt das heißt also wie schon
erwähnt ich sehe natürlich nur die
schweren verläufe
ich sehe nur menschen die zum größten
teil daran versterben das bedeutet
natürlich nicht dass jeder in der
bevölkerung da draußen einen schweren
verlauf erleiden wird oder an dieser
krankheit sterben wird
aber diese betriebsblindheit möchten sie
alle zurück geben jeder der nicht auf
eine intensivstation arbeitet jeder der
nicht im privaten umfeld davon betroffen
ist sieht die leichten verläufen oder
sieht vielleicht nur menschen die gar
nicht an krebs erkranken und das
wiederum heißt nicht dass es diese
schweren verläufe eben nicht gibt wir
bewegen uns in letzter zeit nur noch in
extremen die extreme so wollen die eine
als auch in die andere richtung führen
dazu dass wir uns immer häufiger an die
gurgel gehen und ich muss ihnen sagen
mir blutet das herz wenn ich sehe dass
jahrelange freundschaften an diesen
debatten zerbrechen oder familien sich
bisher so zerstreiten einfach weil jeder
eine andere meinung hat und andere
meinungen sind wichtig und meinung muss
man auch in dieser zeit äußern dürfen
aber immer unter moralischen grundsätzen
also meinungsfreiheit ist ja nicht
endlos und somit sollte man immer wenn
man seine meinung äußert genau überlegen
wie sagt man die also was was was wenn
man mitteilen und welche botschaft
bringe ich darüber
am ende möchte ich noch sagen dass seit
einem jahr hat spanier wollen wieder
gesagt immer davon gesprochen wird dass
man die intensivstation nicht überlasten
will also die kliniken und ganz speziell
die intensivstationen
ich muss sagen wenn es eine
intensivstation nicht mehr schafft alle
aufkommenden patienten und hier reden
wir nicht nur von provieh das gibt auch
schlaganfälle
verkehrsunfälle usw zu beherbergen
und diese patienten in anderen
abteilungen der klinik die zu
provisionen intensivstation
umfunktioniert boden verlegt werden es
also die ein patient der normalerweise
auf einer intensivstation gehört in
einem anderen bereich verlegt wird wo
natürlich auch das personal was diesen
patienten betreut natürlich gar nicht
geschult und ausgebildet ist im umgang
mit intensiv richtigen patienten dann
ist die intensivstation bereits
überlastet und da gibt es nach meiner
meinung keinen interpretationsspielraum
und bis heute habe ich noch kein
schlüssiges um funktionierendes konzept
vorgelegt bekommen was in zukunft zum
einen solche szenarien verhindert aber
auch und pflegekräfte in unserer arbeit
unterstützt und ein normales
familienleben wieder möglich macht und
gerne stehe ich dem
bundesgesundheitsministerium und somit
auch ein sparen dafür in zukunft
weiterhin zur verfügung
vielen dank vielen dank herr langer wir
kommen zu ihren fragen und wir beginnen
mit der bitte dann auf relativ kurze
antworten nimmt genau viele viele fragen
die ich auf dem teller und online
eingegangen sind
mit enrique herr dankeschön die frage
geht sowohl in spanien als auch herr
wieder
sie haben jetzt normale auf die
besorgniserregende lage hingewiesen aber
ich wollte mal anders dann fragen sie
sagen jetzt die zahlen pendeln sich bei
150 bis 170 1
aber dann muss man nicht trotzdem
angesichts der zahlen entwicklung von
einer trendwende reden die ja auch bei
den nachbarstaaten dazu geführt hat dass
die bereits wieder den weg von öffnungs
schritten gehen also warum sind sie so
zögerlich jetzt auch eine positive
entwicklung die sich ja anscheinend für
die zahlen zeigt
zu nennen also ich nehm ich schaue wie
viele andere auch jeden tag mehrfach auf
die zahlen in die welt und natürlich
habe ich mich die letzten zwei drei tage
gefolgt
über zurückgehen der inzidenz übers
zurückgehen der zahlen im vergleich zur
vorwoche das abschwächende dynamik die
verlängerung der verdopplung zeit alle
parameter sind erstmal so sogar zwei
drei tage wo es leicht sehr leicht aber
bei den absoluten zahlen der
intensivpatienten zurückgegangen ist
aber meine erfahrung hat jetzt nach 14
monaten ist auch zwei drei tage ist noch
kein trend in diesem infektionsgeschehen
zumal manche der parameter ja auch erst
das geschehen von vor ein bis zwei
wochen abbilden und deswegen ist das ja
erst mal ein gutes signal aber das
entscheidende ist ja dass wir jetzt
daraus ein trend machen zusammen und das
ist jetzt auch die balance in der
kommunikation was ich vorher mit meinte
etwas etwas salopp zugegebenermaßen mit
mit verstolpern
es darf jetzt nicht heißen dass wenn wir
von 165 auf 140 runter sind das dann
alle sagen okay dann haben wir es ja
geschafft zielmarke ist unter 100 damit
die bundes notbremse als solche gar
nicht mehr in kraft ist und umso weiter
runter desto besser denn umso weiter
runter wir jetzt kommen desto besser
werden wir mit den impfungen die weiter
steigen die dinge
gut ob abschließend weiß ich nicht aber
zumindest ist das potenzial dafür da
unter kontrolle bekommen können und
deswegen freue ich mich über den letzten
zwei drei tage und die entwicklung aber
die erfahrung macht halt auch vorsichtig
ich glaube ist es besser hier vorsichtig
zu sein bevor wir schon trend trends
verkünden ja da zwei wochen ist ja in
der bundesschnitt in etwa gleich
geblieben und jetzt ist es zum ersten
mal geht also ein bisschen runter
ich sehe das genauso das ist ein kurzer
trend aber schauen sie sich doch die
einzelnen bundesländer an
die sind doch sehr unterschiedlich wir
haben ein bundesland das ist schleswig
holstein
das liegt so um die 70 pro 100 glaube
ich pro 100000 etwas gibt andere
bundesländer sachsen thüringen
sie liegen weit über 200 also das ist
doch klar wir müssen doch einfach lernen
dass wir genauer hinschauen und wir
müssen die zahlen insgesamt
runterbringen die gründe haben sie jetzt
alle zum wiederholten male gehört es
reicht nicht und es wäre schön ich bin
jeder in meinem institut ist glücklich
über jede incident sie nach unten geht
aber wir müssen sie eben und beurteilen
sie es ist zu früh von einem trend zu
reden ärger erspart ich wollte sie
fragen wie sie die ankündigung des
bayern keck gründers werten impfungen
für kinder etwa oder wann rechnen sie
damit dass auch kinder geimpft und damit
gegen das virus geschützt sein können
also eine bessere einschätzung als
diejenigen die da jeden tag daran
forschen und entwickeln kann ich
tatsächlich nicht geben
und als herrscher ihn und sein team was
wir sehen und das ist ja erst mal schon
mal sehr ermutigend ist dass es eine
zulassung für ab 12 jahren für diesen
impfstoff von biontech
in den usa gibt dass die jetzt auch für
die europäische arzneimittelagentur es
sind leichte unterschiede immer in den
geforderten unterlagen und verfahren
aber auch nur leichte jetzt zügig auch
erfolgen wird und kann und ich rechne
dann auch mit der zügigen zulassung und
das wird uns wenn es so kommt die
möglichkeit geben
spätestens in den sommerferien für den
schulstart die über 12 jährigen dann
schon mal zu impfen
und das wäre schon ein sehr wichtiger
unterschied weil wir sehen in der sie
haben der gratis-app wie es heißt also
die frage sieht man jetzt immer aus der
entfernung nicht aber das wir je hatten
ist über ganz lange zeit dass in den
älteren altersgruppen ist sehr dunkel
rot war und jetzt sehen wir impfung und
gleichzeitig ist es jetzt bei den
jüngeren und gerade auch bei den 26
jährigen ein deutlich überproportionales
infektionsgeschehen und das würde sehr
helfen wenn diese zulassung für über
zwölfter ist das nächste schritt ist
natürlich wir bekommen auch wir
schreiben nachvollziehbarerweise von
eltern etwa mit kindern die feuer krank
und die sich natürlich sorgen wie sie
diese kinder auch durch impfung schützen
können ist dann der nächste schritt für
unter 12-jährige dann nehme ich erst mal
zur kenntnis wie optimistisch erscheinen
die lage einschätzt und ich würde mich
freuen wenn es so wenn es so gelingen
kann
also das ist ja beschrieben auch das
verfahren das sozusagen dann das alter
runter geschaut wird wie verträgt jemand
mit zwölf wenn es gut läuft mit elf mit
in den studien dann die dosis und den
impfstoff die vermutung ist ja oder die
prognose dass man bis sechs monate
möglicherweise eine impfung angebot wird
machen können das wäre natürlich super
aber eine bessere zeitschiene
vorherzusagen als die forscher selbst
traue ich mir nicht so satt gibt es denn
bei einem haus erste planungen sie
sagten jetzt sommerferien erscheinen hat
glaube ich juni gesagt er gibt es da
schon zeitliche planungen und wie stellt
man sich das bei ihnen raus ganz
praktisch vor
also würde man dann ins ärzte in die
schulen schicken oder soll das über die
hausärzte laufen gibt es da schon
der praktische überlegungen also über
das wie gibt es tatsächlich mehrere wege
die kinderärzte können ja die impfen
glaube ich mehr machen als fast jeder
andere als gruppe war natürlich
insbesondere in jungen jahren ja viel
geld wird zum schutz die kinder und
jugendärzte würden natürlich wie
hausärzte alle anderen arztgruppen auch
mit impfen können aber das ein thema das
wir natürlich auch mit den ländern
besprechen wie auch das impfen etwa
stadtteilbezogenen die diskussion der
letzten tage
sie haben ende organisation vor ort ich
hab gestern auch eine schalte gehabt mit
dem städtetag dem städte- und
gemeindebund und dem landkreistag wo wir
auch über diese frage gesprochen haben
am ende können die das am besten
pragmatisch vor ort entscheiden ob es
jetzt besser ist in die schule zu gehen
und die schülerin idealerweise gleich
mit den eltern mit wenn sie wollen also
wir kommen ja im sommer in die phase wo
allerdings wirklich geben werden wollen
geimpft sind wo es dann darum geht es ja
niedrigschwellig auch denen die
vielleicht keinen arzt termin machen
würden oder wir immer dann zu erreichen
und dann könnte das eben auch natürlich
in den schulen stattfinden als reine
impfungen wie andere impfungen auch im
juni kommen halt wir müssen jetzt ein
bisschen alle aufpassen mit diesem juni
dass der nicht so überfrachtet mit
erwartungen
es kommen im juni so viele impfstoffe
wie noch keinen monat zuvor
aber es kommen jetzt nicht so viel dass
wir alle zwischen 12 und 60 mal eben im
juni impfen können das finde ich jetzt
sehr sehr wichtig dass nicht überall der
eindruck entsteht sozusagen im juni ist
denn jetzt für alle alles
durch impfungen die wollen jedenfalls
erledigt und deswegen werden wir jetzt
nicht einfach sagen können es schon mal
dann alle jugendlichen und haben dann
bei den 50 jährigen noch nicht alle
geimpft das kann ich jetzt noch nicht
ende april so abschließend für juni
sagen aber spätestens in den
sommerferien das kann ich sagen die
prognose traue ich mir zu stand heute
wenn nichts ungewöhnliches passiert
spätestens in den sommerferien werden
wir die über 12 jährigen dann impfen
können wenn die zulassung da ist
kohlenstoff beschaffung angeht so viel
impfstoff für die kinder da sind und
manchmal hat man darauf gelernt den
letzten jahren das wird es anders laufen
also zuerst einmal sehen wir zumindest
jetzt bei dem über 12 jährigen wo es in
den usa heißt es immer wichtig bisher
die zulassung gibt in europa noch nicht
aber wir gehen davon aus dass es sie
daneben geben wird bei den über 12
jährigen ist es ja der gleiche impfstoff
die gleiche dosierung das wird also den
davon haben wir ausreichend menge sie
wissen einer unser haupt vertragspartner
in der europäische union ist bei montech
ist auch unser hauptlieferant im zweiten
quartal auch noch ein wichtiger im
dritten quartal so dass dafür diese
frage ausreichend menge da sein wird ob
es für ein kinder impfung eine andere
dosierung braucht eine andere
zusammensetzung insgesamt das kann man
eben noch nicht sagen
die neuen verträge die die europäische
union schließt beinhalten ausdrücklich
auch die möglichkeit der anpassung dann
sozusagen oder der wahlmöglichkeit dann
welche art kinder oder erwachsene
impfstoff jetzt würden wir das dann
individuell mit dem hersteller sozusagen
nachziehen und nachverhandeln falls es
eine andere dosis braucht aber wir haben
inklusive der kinder und jugendlichen
ausreichend mengen gesichert das ist
jetzt nicht nur bei montech die studien
machen für kinder und jugendliche
sondern
alle anderen hersteller auch so dass wir
auch da ja mit weiteren zulassungen
rechnen
ganz wichtig ist was wir gerade sehr
aktiv unterstützen begleiten die
ankündigung der eu-kommission die
verhandlungen der eu kommission jetzt
mit bajonett im ersten schritt über 1,8
milliarden dosen 900 bis 900 millionen
optional für 20 22 23 das ist ja genau
das was hier angesprochen haben sehr
frühzeitig auch die folgejahre mögliche
booster impfung mögliche mutations
impfung mitzudenken und diese verträge
beinhalten diese klausel sehr sehr
explizit übrigens beinhalten auch ganz
anders die frage von was ist wenn nicht
zu einem zeitpunkt geliefert wird dann
habe ich zwei fragen online sich auch
mit ihnen beschäftigen
erst mal eine hummel von der ärzte
zeitung es gibt forderungen ersparen in
sozialen brennpunkt einen schwerpunkt
beim impfen zu setzen da die zahl der
infektionen dort sehr hoch sei wie ist
und wann lässt sich das sicherstellen
braucht es hierfür die aus ärzte und
herzlichen divani von herrn de fragt
teilen sie die einschätzung von
vizekanzler scholz nun auch die
aufrechterhaltung der impro
priorisierung auch deshalb wichtig ist
und ein soziales ungleichgewicht bei der
reihenfolge zu verhindern
da hängt ja auch miteinander zusammen
zum ersten was die soziale brennpunkte
oder bestimmte lebenssituationen
lebenswelten angeht ist natürlich sehr
sehr wichtig das gilt ja für andere
präventions- und impfkampagnen im
übrigen auch sehr niedrigschwellig immer
zu erreichen erreichen zu können
darüber habe ich wie gesagt jetzt mit
den kommunalen spitzenverbänden
gesprochen werde ich heute heute ist es
noch mal eine schalte mit den landes
kollegen auch mit den landes kollegen
sprechen
das können wir nicht vom bodensee ich
kann nicht aus dem bund die richtige
impfkampagne für essen leipzig oder oder
offenbach plan was wir können ist die
sicherheit geben dass bei der
mitfinanzierung des bundes zum beispiel
bei den impfzentren strukturen die als
mobile strukturen aus den impfzentren
heraus entstehen etwa in sozialen
brennpunkten mitfinanziert werden dass
wir das mittragen
das wäre dass regelungsbedarf gibt etwas
flexibler zu machen das ist schon
eigentlich alles ziemlich flexibel aber
auch dass das zu machen und eben die
informationskampagnen
die machen wir schon seit beginn der
ziemlich seit beginn der pandemie
mehrsprachig mittlerweile in über 20
sprachen die telefonhotlines sind zum
teil auch mittlerweile mehr sprach ich
wir machen bei social media mehr als wir
hier alle im raum wahrnehmen weil es
natürlich zielgruppenspezifische
ansprache auch dort dann dann gibt und
wir werden auch mit influenza wie wir
sie nennen findet die offenkundig jung
nicht überzeugend aber jedenfalls mit
allen die mitmachen wollen
bei diesen kampagnen ob bei installer
anderen sozialen medien aber auch in den
klassischen werbe und
informationskampagnen auch natürlich mit
role models fußballspieler sind ob wir
haben jetzt ein glas sepp maier zum
beispiel weil wir im moment ja auch noch
die kampagne vor allem auf die
generation ausgerichtet haben wohl die
glas ja durch den einen oder anderen
filmen auch jüngeren durchaus ein
begriff ist erst mal wie man es auch
generation adressiert natürlich und
damit dann auch zielgruppen adressiert
was eben kulturelle religiöse
zusammenhänge angeht also ich will zum
beispiel auch gerne mit den
religionsgemeinschaften darüber reden ob
und in welcher weise ob sie christlichen
kirchen sind ob es russisch orthodoxe
kirche ist optimal sind
ob und in welcher weise auch
religionsgemeinschaften mit bereit sind
dafür zu werben
die frage der impf priorisierung und der
risiken für soziale ungleichgewichte das
ist ja das thema dass wir generell bei
gesundheit und präventionsangeboten
haben das gti gesundheitsbewusst leben
in aller regel auch eine entsprechende
bildung einfach auch haben und wissen
darüber haben wie man sich diese muss
mich ja auch lernen gesundheitsbewusstes
verhalten muss man auch lernen ist eine
frage tatsächlich auch von bildung und
erziehung und den unterschied gibt es
jenseits dieser impfkampagne auch in
anderen bereichen und wir versuchen ihn
bestmöglich generell bei gesundheits vor
interessieren und auch hier zu
adressieren da sind die hausärzte ganz
ganz wichtig in den stadtteilen und
dafür sind aber auch die kampagne
wichtig die ich gerade an
auch ein habe das ist aber nicht per
sehen thema der priorisierung sondern
eher eine frage der wirklich zielgruppen
und soziale gruppen spezifischen
ansprach coli vielen dank pkw-halter
deutsches ärzteblatt ich wollte mal
nachfragen hat über kinder gerade
gesprochen was ist denn mit den
schwangeren da gibt es jetzt ja auch
erste diskussionen vielleicht erspart
sie als bewertung überhaupt herr wieder
was in der wasser- oder auch in der
spekulation momentan diskutiert wird
also die momentane stiko empfehlung ist
sehr geprägt von dem momentanen wissen
über die impfung bei schwangeren was ist
bis jetzt gibt ist das heißt habe ich im
fachjargon tendenziell oder so ähnlich
akzents ils akzidenz ii l ist also eher
zufälliges impfen von schwangeren von
leuten von frauen die noch nicht gewusst
haben dass sie schwanger sind geimpft
worden sind und die erfahrung die man da
hat zeigen dass das jedenfalls da keine
negativen einflüsse hat das ist ja die
frage hat es welche oder nicht ist auch
die sorge die viele haben andersrum
haben viele an die sorge und das
bedürfnis sich gerade in der
schwangerschaft zu schützen
durch eine impfung und dafür ist eben
die auswertung der studienlage wichtig
und ich habe gerade heute morgen noch
kontakt gehabt auch mit dem professor
maertens die ständige impfkommission
schaut sich das beständig an und wird
ihre empfehlung in dem moment wo es eine
entsprechende datenlage dafür gibt auch
anpassen
im moment ist sie ja noch zurückhaltend
bei der entsprechenden empfehlung weil
sie eben sagt dafür ist die datenlage
noch nicht da sagt aber gleichzeitig
immer auch da wo es passiert etwa wenn
man noch gar nicht weiß dass man
schwanger ist gibt es aber auch keinen
anlass zur beunruhigung
ich kann das nur insofern ergänzt dass
die stiko natürlich kontinuierlich alle
die dinge die wir hier diskutieren etwa
das impfen von kindern von bestimmten
risikogruppen das natürlich
kontinuierlich im robert-koch-institut
und auch als serviceleistung für die
stiko natürlich die ganze zeit die
weltliteratur die studien gesichtet
werden um das
wir wissen immer aktuell zu halten aber
ich möchte mal vielleicht noch mal eine
zahl sagen um wie noch einzuschätzen
dass wir eben noch eine menge zu tun
haben beim impfen also von den über
80-jährigen sind nur rund etwa zwei
drittel bis halb lang ist auch dass sie
das mal wahrnehmen es gibt noch eine
menge über 80-jährige sind noch nicht
geimpft und von über 70 jahren sind es
nur 30 prozent etwa die geimpft sind
also da ist noch ein weg zu gehen und
auch einer der gründe warum wir
natürlich bei der einschätzung einfach
wirklich sachlich vorsichtig sein müssen
wir impfen sehr schnell und viel aber es
sind auch sehr viele die noch geimpft
werden müssen und wir müssen auch weiter
hoffen dass die impfbereitschaft zu hoch
bleibt das sondern aspekt den wir nicht
vergessen dürfen insofern ist es wichtig
dass die leute alle irgendwo angebot
annehmen und die stiko arbeitet
kontinuierlich an den neuen
erkenntnissen die in deutschland und
anderen ländern bereitschaft der
bevölkerung sagen ich finde einfach ist
hat auch viel mit der kommunikation auch
hier von der politik zu tun aber auch
generell in den medien ebenfalls stehe
einfach nicht warum man von privilegien
schon spricht wenn noch nicht mal die
ganze bevölkerung ein impfangebot
erhalten hat und ich finde das
verunsichert zusätzlich es gibt ja viele
wer sich sagen impfgegner aber es gibt
schon welche die skeptisch sind und ich
finde jeder sollte seine entscheidung
treffen nicht durch druck weil man
irgendwelche privilegien möchte oder
weil man vielleicht sogar eine
impfpflicht befürchtet aber auch nicht
durch hetze ich finde eine sachliche und
kompetente aufklärung ist notwendig und
wir sollten erst über privilegien
sprechen wenn jedem einzelnen
bundesbürger hier ein impfangebot
gemacht werden konnte und auch das ist
meine meinung dazu ich hätte eine frage
ein händler
villa diese variante b 16 17 die
verbreitet wie weit verbreitet ist die
dann in deutschland und ist
abschottenden überhaupt eine option weil
das hätte er bei der so genannten
britischen variante auch überhaupt nicht
funktioniert ja wir haben einzelne fälle
in deutschland wir werden glaube ich
morgen oder so den neuen bericht heraus
bringen also einzelfälle gibt es bereits
und natürlich beobachten wir dass man
muss zu der variante folgendes sagen sie
hat von den genetischen merkmalen
also von den genetischen veränderungen
insbesondere in dem spalt protein was
was ja für diese anheftung sehr wichtig
sind für die monatlich dies hat sie ein
paar signale die vermuten lassen dass
sie vielleicht einen gewissen immun ist
hat es gibt auch erste
laboruntersuchungen dazu allerdings sind
die nicht so dass wir da sehr sehr
beunruhigt sind wenn wir uns das
geschehen in indien anschauen dann muss
man ist das für uns nicht so ganz
einfach nachzuvollziehen was dort
geschieht aber klar ist dass dort ja
aufgrund vieler sozialer umstände eines
völlig anderen lebens systems eines
völlig anderen gesundheitssystems dass
man doch lockerungen durchführen musste
weil dort einfach die gefahr zu groß war
dass in vielen teilen der bevölkerung
menschen einfach verhungern
wir haben eben nicht so ein sozialsystem
wie das bei uns der fall ist und dass
dort durch viele kulturelle
veranstaltungen dem virus sehr viel
freiraum auch gegeben wurde dass muss
man ganz deutlich sagen wir können also
momentan noch gar nicht endgültig
belegen ob das virus schneller
verbreitet wird es gibt auch eine andere
eine menge andere varianten die dort
unterwegs sind wir haben keine guten
abdeckung bei der genotypisierung also
insofern ist das noch eine offene frage
und es ist aus meiner sicht nach wie vor
richtig das war lieber vorsorglich
bisschen vorsichtiger sind als das war
zu gucken
ich will noch eine sache sagen die sie
vielleicht nicht alle im blick haben
in england ist ausreise illegal briten
dürfen nicht ins ausland reisen das ist
eh liegen officially das heißt also wer
dort ins ausland reisen will in england
der mussten trifft den grund haben wir
uns zahlt eine hohe strafe also die
engländer die haben ihre zahlen eben
auch jetzt da nicht nur der impfung zu
verdanken und die haben ja auch wirklich
ein extrem harten locker und gemacht der
seit kurzem geöffnet ist und die
engländer fahren einen sehr harten kurs
um die zahlen so günstig zu halten wie
sie sind das sind maßnahmen die man über
die man absolut diskutieren muss also
per als bundesregierung in diskutieren
über letzter genannte maßnahme nicht um
jetzt nicht die debatte von vor vier
wochen wieder zu beginnen
also wichtig ist ist
was die brasilianisch also sie natürlich
leichter den eintrag aus ländern zu
reduzieren wo es praktisch nur
flugverkehr gibt als den eintrag aus
direkten nachbarländern siehe
tschechische republik zu reduziert was
gelungen ist ist aber zum beispiel ja
die sogenannte südafrika variante die im
bereich modell grund es also bei unseren
französischen nachbarn im grenzgebiet
sehr verbreitet war und im saarland
stark überproportional war auch durch
die verstärkte impfung im saarland das
war eine bewusste entscheidung mehr
impfdosen ins saarland zu geben und
durch die maßnahmen an der grenze unter
kontrolle zu halten und deswegen jahr
bei der britischen variante haben wir
gesehen wie sie zur dominierenden
geworden ist wir haben es aber bisher
jedenfalls geschafft die anderen
varianten eben nicht sich hier in
deutschland ausbreiten zu lassen und das
ist naturgemäß beim ländern die nur per
flug zu erreichen sind etwas leichter
herr spahn jetzt haben sie eben gesagt
worüber die bundesregierung nicht
diskutiert die us-demokraten haben
aktuell gefordert ein zeitweiliges
verzicht auf die patente das ist eine
position zu der die bundesregierung
bislang auch nicht bereit war unter dem
eindruck dieser diskussion und
anknüpfend an den satz von professor
wiler dass es eben erst im griff ist
eins weltweit im griff ist muss nicht
die bundesregierung jetzt auch überlegen
ob sie sich einer solchen forderung
zeitweiliger verzicht auf patente um
überall dort wo das technisch und
technologisch möglich ist im stoff zu
produzieren so widmann so da diese zu
unterstützen
die eigentliche frage ist dort noch mal
ob das sozusagen das tatsächliche
problem adressiert haben wir im moment
das problem dass die hersteller die
patente haben die erstellen können nicht
bereit sind mehr zu produzieren um die
welt zu impfen den eindruck habe ich
absolut nicht im gegenteil ich nehme
wahr wie alle hersteller
kooperationspartner auf der ganzen welt
suchen um mehr zu produzieren und planen
teilweise zu
zwei bis drei milliarden dosen pro monat
pro jahr herzustellen
insofern haben wir ja überhaupt nicht
das problem dass irgendjemand nicht
ausreichend herstellen will und auch
nicht nicht bereit wäre es für alle
länder auf der welt zur verfügung zu
stellen
die frage ist ja sozusagen wie ist die
verfügbarkeit dann tatsächlich faktisch
auch was preise und marktzugang angeht
und da engagieren wir uns sehr sehr
stark kovacs weltgesundheitsorganisation
es also der ex-trainer der
weltgesundheitsorganisation finanziell
wir engagieren uns übrigens auch sehr
stark indem wir die hersteller in
deutschland unterstützen ihre
produktionskapazitäten aufzubauen
das problem das ich sehe für das ich
gestern noch in den deutsch chinesischen
regierungskonsultationen geworben habe
dass wir alle er sicher sind wenn alle
sicher sind und es keine weißen flecken
auf der welt geben sollte in der
gesundheits zusammenarbeit das problem
adressiert man doch am besten indem man
die menge außerdem produziert und
verfügbar macht und das ist genau das
was passiert nachfrage
es gibt ja das prinzip das eine tun und
das andere nicht lassen
wir haben sie in der jüngeren
vergangenheit erlebt dass es doch immer
noch nicht hinreichend versorgung mit
impfstoffen gab
wenn bei uns die weltbevölkerung
angucken sind die zahlen enorm
und was spricht dagegen dass dort wo an
anderer stelle neue zusätzliche
kapazitäten aufgebaut werden können
man sagt wir geben euch das recht dazu
was vermutlich auch gerade für die
länder des globalen südens eine
reduzierung bei den preisen für magazine
bedeuten würden was ja auch nicht
schlecht wäre
warum sperrt sich die bundesregierung
dagegen ich teile schlechten ergreifend
dabei eine unterschiedliche auffassung
halten wir aber ja auch dann aus ich
teile einfach die analyse nicht dass es
nicht die bereitschaft gebe mit anderen
zu kooperieren und möglichst viel
herzustellen wenn sie mir ein konkretes
beispiel bringen häufig selbst mit dass
die kooperation stattfindet die
notwendig ist wo eine kooperation nicht
stattgefunden hat mit einem
hersteller in einem land der bereit
gewesen wäre herzustellen unter den
bedingungen natürlich die dafür
notwendig sind in guter
herstellungspraxis dass es zu machen ist
es ist ich finde wir müssen halt immer
schon besprechen wir das richtige
probleme und das war aus meiner sicht
schon für die deutsche versorgungslage
anfang des jahres die jetzt für die
internationale versorgungslage nicht das
problem dass es patente gibt sondern
eher die frage erstens wie eskalieren
wir produktionskapazitäten hoch das
passiert wie entstehen kooperation
passiert jeden tag schauen wir morgen
noch eine an in reinbek für zusätzliche
produktionskapazitäten für europa und
die welt und wie kriegen sie es dann in
die länder und die rückmeldung die wir
im moment haben ist er und das ist die
schwierigkeit die wir selbst bis hin zu
hiv medikamenten in afrika haben ist ja
gar nicht die verfügbarkeit des
medikamentes sondern die frage gibt es
überhaupt ein gesundheitssystem das
diese medikamente oder in diesem fall
diese impfstoff für die menschen
erreichen können
also ist tatsächlich der impfstoff hier
die schwierigkeit dann zu erreichen wenn
er verfügbar ist und er wird auch dazu
nimmt verfügbar sein
oder es ist ein gesundheitssystem das
sozusagen in teilen nicht mehr vorhanden
ist
ich will drei fragen zusammen fassen sie
sich alle mit rechten für geimpften
befassen
bischoff spd fragt prinzipiell
bundestags präsentabel oft wirkt für
eine regelung zur hälfte schon anfang
mai nicht erst ende mai wie stehen sie
zu einer beschleunigung dieses
verfahrens und eine verabschiedung der
verordnung schon im laufe der nächsten
woche herr buchsteiner fragt wir sehen
jetzt die konkrete konkrete zeitplan und
die inhalte aus die sie vorschlagen und
gibt es auch eine regelung für
pflegeheime geben und herr davis von der
rheinischen post fragt wie sollen
genießen ihre infektion einige monate
zurück liegt künftig den nachweis
erbringen um mehr freiheiten zu erhalten
braucht es dazu antikörpertest also zum
ersten was die frage der zeitplan angeht
niemand wird der was haben gegen ein
zügiges verfahren und mein eindruck ist
so sind ja auch die rückmeldung dass
sowohl der bundestag wie der bundesrat
die ja beide bei dieser verordnung als
besondere regelung zu beteiligen sind
auch bereit sind das dann zügig
gegebenenfalls in sondersitzungen zu
machen
viel wichtiger ist aber dann damit ist
das bringt ja nichts eine sitzung zu
haben wenn es nicht vorher einen
konsensfähigen entwurf gibt also wo in
welcher situation wir ja nicht kommen
dürfen ist ja die dass die
bundesregierung einen vorschlag macht
wenn der bundestag maßgabe dass und
änderungs beschlüsse dazu macht ist
zurück spielt an die bundesregierung und
das dann so ein pingpong wird und das
gleiche damit dem bundesrat noch einmal
passiert sondern wenn dann sollte sie
idealerweise ja ein entwurf seien der
mehrheitsfähig ist sowohl im bundestag
wie im bundesrat idealerweise schon wenn
die bundesregierung ihn in die
beratungsverfahren gibt das ist bei
einer verordnung etwas anders als beim
gesetzentwurf sie können nicht im
bundestag änderungsanträge stellen und
deswegen aufgrund dieses besonderen
verfahrens für diese verordnung bemühen
wir uns bundesregierung seit ich sehr
und werden uns darum bemühen dass wenn
wir unseren erstentwurf jetzt zeitnah
abgestimmt haben
zwischen den beteiligten ressorts
daneben auch schon mit bundestag und
bundesrat zu reden die gespräche werden
sich ja auch schon nächste woche
stattfinden irgendwie schnell ist ein
konsens gibt
das liegt ja dann in allen beteiligten
in diesem in diesen fragen was aber ganz
wichtig ist und das muss man jetzt noch
mal wenn ich noch mal darf unterscheiden
die regelungen zu wie verhält sich
geimpft sein zu getestet sein oder
getestet sein zu geimpft seien hier um
eines betrachten möchte die können wir
alle machen sie gerade auch zügig machen
detail geht zügig das sind
landesverordnung sind zum teil kommunale
verordnung meinetwegen klicken mieth mit
tests erfordern ist das gleich zu
stellen geht schnell ein reiseverordnung
gleichzustellen geht auch
vergleichsweise schnell sind wir gerade
in der erarbeitung gehe ich davon aus
dass nächste woche der entwurf da ist
die empfehlung zum quarantäne des
robert-koch-instituts anzupassen ging
auch vergleichsweise schnell ist seit
zwei wochen in kraft wird von den
gesundheitsämtern vor ort umgesetzt
es sind viele maßnahmen in umsetzung
oder wurden schon umgesetzt die sowohl
in den rechtlichen verfahren
verordnung bundesrat bundestag zustimmen
wie in der inhaltlichen ausprägung und
wir haben ja gerade gesehen von von
herrn lange bis anderen gibt es sehr
unterschiedliche einschätzung zu der
frage wie verhält sich individuellen
freiheitsrecht in einer pandemie mit
gesundheitsschutz und und und
durchsetzungsfähigkeit von rechten
insgesamt eine sehr grundsätzliche
juristische und gesellschaftliche und
ethische abwägungsfrage die wir
natürlich in unserer freiheitlichen
grundordnung zuerst noch immer vom
freiheits aspekt her denken müssen
das wird eine debatte sein das ist das
komplexeste die halt nächste woche
sicherlich auf basis des entwurfs ist
dann sehr intensiv geführt wird wenn man
es eigentlich sind geht schnell und dann
war noch die frage pflegeheime dort
haben wir ja seitens der
gesundheitsminister von bund und ländern
empfehlungen schon gemacht dass für
lockerungen pflegeeinrichtung viele
länder und übrigens auch schon umgesetzt
wenn sie jetzt auch mit
pflegeeinrichtungen kontakte haben
sozusagen ob privat oder dienstlich
beschreiben ja alle dass ihr
arbeitsalltag auch an oder arbeit
falsche lebensalltag für die profis
pflegenden der arbeitsalltag aber
erstmal für die bewohnerinnen und
bewohner ihr lebensalltag dass der
lebensalltag schon deutlich wieder
normaler geworden ist die möglichkeit
sich zu treffen gemeinsam zu essen
gemeinsame aktionen zu machen
das ist schon so und das wird man
natürlich auch weiter fortsetzen können
und das robert koch institut untersucht
ja auch jeden fall eines impfstoffes in
einer pflegeeinrichtung auch
gleichzeitig sehr intensiv die erfahrung
ist dass es in aller regel von außen
reingetragen ist das aber gleichzeitig
dann die verläufe eben nicht mehr so
brutal sind in den einrichtungen und die
verbreitung wie wir es bisher sehen das
ist ja erst mal gut und gibt diese
möglichkeit genesene waren auch die
frage und genießen den nachweis ist
schlicht und ergreifend der pcr test
also dass die dokumentation des
negativen testergebnisses ist ja mit
datum versehen
falls sie die nicht mehr haben müsste im
zweifel die stelle die sie getestet hat
ihr hausarzt oder das gesundheitsamt
ihnen das noch mal beschleunigen oder
ausstellen einen antikörpertest 3
deswegen nicht weil eben ja auch
antikörper teilweise deutlich schneller
weg sind nicht mehr nachweisbar band
obwohl die immunität die hier vor allem
auch eine immunität der t zellen ist
konnte jetzt aber eine monologe besser
herleiten als ich durch antikörper
nachweise nicht gemessen werden können
und zweitens auch nicht wann es geht ja
auch um sechs monate also brauchen wir
ein datum und deswegen ist das pcr test
ergebnis entweder direkt noch selbst
vorhanden
ich habe meinen es noch oder aber durch
den der es damals ausgestellt hat
nochmal erneut ausgestellt dann das
mittel der wahl wenn man jetzt weiter in
der reihenfolge herr okaka dann in der
mitte und der jung mutter katrin 19
vielen dank herr minister sie haben
vorhin selber gesagt wir kommen
demnächst in eine situation in der sehr
viele gleichzeitig berechtigt sein
werden und das dann natürlich alles
nicht ganz schön ich ja nicht jeder
erwarten kann dass er sofort dann der
erste ist gerade vor diesem hintergrund
müsste man nicht überlegen gerade jungen
menschen die jetzt durch durch
unterbrechungen bei studium schule
ausbildung wirklich große probleme
hatten ein jahr lang vielleicht doch
schon in die im trio drei zu nehmen also
schüler ab 16 die schon ein impfstoff
kriegen können studierende und auch
vielleicht azubis ist das eine
überlegung die bei ihnen wie es bei
ihnen gibt und einmal kurz noch ein
händler
wie sicher sind wir inzwischen
eigentlich genau das ein zweifach
geimpfter wirklich niemanden mehr
anstecken
also zur frage der priorisierung die
priorisierung ja auch auf empfehlung der
ständigen impfkommission geht ja vor
allem von der frage herr auch wo ist
sozusagen das risiko für schwerst- und
schwere verläufe am höchsten
oder wo gibt es bestimmte
arbeitssituation etwa auf der
intensivstation im übrigen
wo es auch eben sinn macht aufgrund des
hohen risikos und des schutzes
derjenigen die man pflegt es arbeitest
dann tatsächlich frühzeitig zu impfen
ich kenne niemanden der dieser pandemie
nicht eingeschränkt ist in seinem alltag
insofern hat natürlich jeder einen
nachvollziehbaren grund warum er oder
sie gerne schnell geimpft werden sollte
oder möchte und ich verstehe das total
mit blick auf schule und hochschule dass
man sagt sollten wir denn da nicht
versuchen auch wieder mehr normalität
möglich zu machen durch impfung
wenn ich aber von dem prinzip her komme
sozusagen der risiken bei der
priorisierung dann finde ich mache es
sinn jetzt im mai vor allem eben diese
priorisierung auch noch umzusetzen sowie
die länder ist ja auch tun wir reden
doch hier über wochen das waren jetzt
und sind jetzt echt harte 14 monate die
ich so noch einmal ich weiß ich erlebe
es ja selber wie hat jeder tag ist und
gleichzeitig ist doch jetzt sommer
sommerferien semesterferien die zeit wo
man also da wären wir alle impfen können
das nächste schuljahr das nächste
semester wird anders starten können als
dieses ende und da kann ich einfach nur
bitten dass wir da gemeinsam diese
letzten wochen noch die geduld aber auch
das verständnis haben für die frage auch
der priorisierung ja die frage die sie
stellen
es wird nie so sein dass alle geimpft
nicht mehr ansteckend sind und keine
viren mehr ausscheiden können aber die
virus ausscheidung wird wenn die
menschen noch mal infiziert werden
natürlich deutlich reduziert wie stark
sie reduziert wird das werden wir noch
weiter sehen in zukünftigen studien aber
ein gewisses restrisiko bleibt natürlich
aber je mehr menschen geimpft werden
desto geringer ist das dann und das ist
ja bei anderen impfungen auch so ja nur
momentan wohl noch so wenig menschen das
möchte einmal erklären die rede war ein
virus das neu ist und gegen das es keine
grund immunität gibt und zwar auf der
ganzen
nicht das heißt also sie werden entweder
krank und entwickelte immunität bei der
krankheit das wollen wir eigentlich
nicht wir wollen die immunität durch
eine impfung haben und solange nicht
genügend menschen geimpft sind müssen
wir eben mehr aufmerksamkeit schenken
dass eine impfung natürlich nicht 100
prozent schützt vor einer infektion und
damit auch von rios ausscheidung das
heißt also diesen aspekt dass eingeimpft
ein endgültiger zwei wochen nach der
zweiten impfung keine wieder ausschaltet
den wird es nicht geben
ja das macht kein impfstoff gelingt
nicht reduziert massiv klar
ihnen gefällt erspart lange hat n-tv ich
würde gerne mal die krone situation bei
kindern anknüpfen der berufsverband von
kindern und jugendärzten spricht sich
dafür aus eltern von jungen kindern
jetzt schnell und priorisiert zu impfen
und sogar kinder schnellstmöglich zu
schützen was halten sie von dem
vorschlag
ich kann den sehr gut nachvollziehen
weil natürlich die frage wenn wir kinder
und jugendliche bis zu einem bestimmten
alter nicht impfen können wie können wir
die schützen indem wir alle um sie herum
impfen
gleichwohl komme ich wieder zu der
antwort von gerade zurück wir können
halt noch nicht
wir können schon deutlich mehr und
deutlich schneller ins angebote machen
wir werden gestern jeden vierten
überschritten haben über 25% ich kann
ihnen leider immer noch nicht genau
sagen wie viel das ist noch in der
zusammentragen von gestern
es gilt aber jedenfalls über 25 prozent
werden wir erreicht haben neben vierten
ein angebot gemacht haben können es
werden jeden tag mehr
aber wir können jetzt nicht noch nicht
all diese themen die sie angesprochen
haben
sie soll in der familie wie sie diese
situation in der hochschule wie sie in
der schule schon durch impfungen
abmildern aber absehbar
können wir es wir werden im juni die
priorisierung aufheben können dann
können wir noch nicht alle impfen
und wenn die lieferung kommen wie
erwartet bereits anfang des sommers
wahrscheinlich schon weiter sein als wir
vor drei monaten noch dachten dass wir
bis ende des monats zusammen was
überhaupt kommen würde und deswegen geht
es jetzt einfach um wochen die bei
eltern die sich sorgen machen und
kindern die sich sorgen machen harte
wochen sind die kann ich nur bitten noch
miteinander durch zwei junge frage an
eine lange lange man könnte ja die
infektions und patientenzahlen effektiv
runter bekommen
man macht es aber man baut darauf dass
sie ihre kollegen täglich am absoluten
limit arbeiten das ding zusammenhalt was
halten sie ein von der strategie von
herrn sparen und der bundesregierung die
kontrolle der pandemie an der
auslastungsgrenze intensivstationen
auszurichten
also sie wollen jetzt wissen was man
immer danach bemisst wie die
intensivstation ausgelastet sind
er habe ja schon gesagt ist äußerst
kritisch weil eine intensivstation
ausgelastet ist sprich die betten belegt
sind und es kommen ja immer mehr wir
reden von krone aber es gibt ja wirklich
schlaganfälle herzinfarkte unfälle
suizidversuche also wir haben ja auf der
intensivstation im breite spektrum von
krankheiten und diese auslastung
strategie die ihr wahrscheinlich auch
gar nicht anders möglich ist ganz als
betriebsblind daher nicht beurteilen
aber ich erlebe es halt täglich dass
eben diese patienten nicht aufgenommen
werden können und das problem ist dass
die patienten dann in anderen
abteilungen wie wünschen erwähnen
verlegt werden
das heißt also da wird zb ein
aufwachraum eines op zwar normalerweise
operierte wach werden und dann verlegt
werden umfunktioniert zu einer
provisorischen intensivstation und
provisorischen deshalb weil eben die
arbeitsbedingungen vor ort er nicht
optimal sind das sind man muss sich
vereinfacht vorstellen verschiedene
halterungen für verschiedene
medizinische geräte und so weiter nicht
vorhanden und provisorischen deshalb bei
der arzt der dort ist kein
intensivmediziner ist sondern meist ein
anästhesist er weist klar der weiß wie
entsteht wird er weiter in der narkose
läuft aber er hat keine erfahrung mit
intensiv pflichtigen patienten also
intensiv intensiv richtiger patient ist
man sehr instabiler patient da laufen
zum beispiel medikamente die
lebensnotwendig sind um den blutdruck um
zu halten und wenn zb nur ganz einfach
gesagt dieses medikament ausläuft für
eine kurze zeit dann verstärkt der
patient weil der blutdruck nicht
aufrecht halten kann
werden kann und zusätzlich arbeitet an
diesem bett in der intensivpflege kraft
eine pflegekraft die eben nicht dazu
ausgebildet und geschult ist um diesen
patienten zu betreuen lässt finde ich
diese strategie so ein bisschen
problematisch weil ist ja nicht nur für
den patienten waren nicht optimal weil
er eben nicht die optimale behandlung
erhält die eigentlich auf der
intensivstation halten sollte aber auch
für das personal was da steht weil die
werden sozusagen ins kalte wasser
geschmissen und sehen sich mit der
verantwortung konfrontiert diesen
patienten betreuen zu müssen
und kommt es zu einer notfallsituation
sind die darauf überhaupt mental nicht
vorbereitet aber auch fachlich nicht
also ja ich hätte mir gewünscht dass wir
mehr kapazitäten also mehr personal
haben bei betten haben wir genug also
man kann den leeren betten
intensivpatienten legen wir mal irgendwo
beatmungsgeräte erholt aber das problem
ist wirklich die personal also es ist ja
nicht nur die pflege soll es auch sind
auch ärzte fehlen sie haben manchmal
auch eine sagen wir mal 30 werden
intensivstation ein facharzt jetzt
überlegen sie jetzt kommt ein patient
egal ob profis oder eine andere
erkrankung der muss notfall intubiert
werden
der facharzt ist gerade bei der
information es haben sie notfall in
einem anderen zimmer und oftmals sind
die pflegekraft die dazu erst handeln
weil der facharzt vor ort ist und zb der
assistenzarzt oder unerfahrene auch
intensivmediziner der eben noch nicht so
lange da ist eben mit dieser
notsituation auch nicht immer so perfekt
umgehen kann also ist halt ich möchte
nur ganz kurz die jungen weil das halt
nicht wahr es ist nicht strategie der
bundesregierung dass die intensivstation
voll werden soll im gegenteil das ist ja
das was eine überlastung ist das was
kritisiert wird an unserer strategie
dass wir schon bei instanzen einsetzen
letzte woche gesagt intensiv folgt der
inzidenz in aller erfahrung in dieser
phase der pandemie jedenfalls noch und
deswegen wollen wir die instanzen runter
bringen bevor intensivstation an ihre
belastungsgrenze gekommen und deswegen
sitze ich hier schon seit vielen wochen
und weise auf die situation hin und habe
bei der debatte im bundestag an
diejenigen die einmal mehr gesagt haben
intensivstationen sind ja noch gar nicht
am limit
warum wollt ihr denn das incidents
abhängen
jetzt schon wie der maßnahmen ergriffen
werden sehr klar gesagt dass ich es für
falsch hielte zu warten bis die
intensivstation voll sind und die grenze
auszutesten und deswegen denke ich schon
wert darauf wenn sie sagen das wäre die
strategie der bundesregierung das ist
sie ausdrücklich nicht im gegenteil
aber die intensivstation sind ja schon
voll
also man muss ja wissen dass eine
intensivstation schon voll war bevor es
corona gab also es gibt immer unfälle
wie schon erwähnt tausende alkoholkranke
die ja im endstadium sind und so weiter
die intensivstation hat normalerweise
außerhalb von corinna zeiten vielleicht
zwei drei freie betten
ich kann ihnen sagen auf der
intensivstation wo ich arbeite sind
entweder komplett voll dann ist uns so
kleine station die haben dann zehn
betten dann werden wir gesagt andere
bereiche in den kliniken umfunktioniert
und auf großen intensivstationen mit
über 30 betten sind mindestens 50% cupid
erkrankte das heißt also 15 betten 20
betten sind mit kodak rang belegt und
diese patienten die vorher lagen sind ja
um parteien also ist die intensivstation
ja schon voll und ich kann mich noch
erinnern schon eine weile her daher
strikt hat der mann belastungstest für
die intensivstation gefordert also ich
wusste nicht ob ich lachen oder freuen
soll
solche menschen sind ja die können wir
von viren erzählen aber die soll noch
mal zu uns ins krankenhaus kommen und
dann können wir die debatte von folgen
oder lernen intensivbetten gerne nochmal
für
also die intensivstation sinnvoll und
wie gesagt da gibt es keine keinen
interpretationsspielraum weil es eben
nicht nur kurven gibt das kommt und ob
obendrauf und die intensivstation waren
vor der pandemie schon deutlich
überlastet aufgrund von personalmangel
es gibt doch in der situation die können
nicht mal alle betten befahren weil eben
das personal nicht da ist dann ist ja
nicht eine debatte die wir es jetzt
führen also gefühlen sie es jetzt werden
sie aber schon vor drei vier fünf jahren
führen sollen
und hätte man früher gehandelt und hätte
man den personalmangel früher ernst
können
dann hätten wir heute nur deutlich
entspannte situation weil wir eben viel
mehr betten hätten belegen aber auch
betreuen können was halten sie denn von
der strategie von herrn wieder der eine
control kurve strategie fordert dass der
dritte spanier nicht und haben sie
eigentlich als zeitarbeiter in pflege
bonus bekommen haben sie einen
spanischen gedankt lange habe die frage
gestanden was halten sie von herrn
bieler ist strategie da hat ja eine
andere strategie vorschlag nämlich
control chor wird also wirklich krass
runter mit den zahlen dass vertreter
sparen ja nicht und haben sie eigentlich
ein pflege bonus bekommen als
zeitarbeiter kontroll kobe darunter mit
den zahlen ja die frage wie macht man es
also fakt ist dass wir ja nicht für
immer in den block dauern fahren können
wird es kein experte da kann er wieder
wahrscheinlich mehr zu sagen aber mein
logisches verständnis ist halt dass man
wie gesagt das wird man wahrscheinlich
nicht ausrotten können denke ich mal so
wahrscheinlich wie mit dem grippevirus
auch mal kann impfen man wird ja man
wurden schwächerem verlauf habe aber den
virus trotzdem in sich haben das sind ja
nur die symptome die abgemildert werden
und es wird immer es wird gibt ja immer
mehr menschen die eben verschiedene
maßnahmen
ich sag jetzt mal auch manchmal zu recht
kritisieren und umso also mich stört zum
beispiel die maßnahme dass sie so wir
sind also ich müsste zum beispiel kommen
aus brandenburg kurz bevor der grenze
von berlin ich müsste quasi googeln was
sich zurzeit darf oder nicht vereinfacht
gesagt das ändert sich denn nicht
und umso verrückter die maßnahmen werden
also verrückt in anführungsstrichen
einfach weil man eben nicht mehr so
richtig durch sieht umso mehr sind da
die menschen natürlich auch verunsichert
und umso weniger halten sich dran
manchmal nicht mal bewusst weil sie eben
gar nicht wissen was ist aktuell die
frage ist wie kann man denn die zahlen
so runter drücken das ist also die frage
kann ich gar nicht beantworten ich lege
bonus haben sie die pflege bonus
bekommen die gewohnten also der pflege
bonus wurde von herrn spart oder
generell von der regierung ja
als anerkennung für die pflege letztes
jahr versprochen und angekündigt auch
das war ja groß in den medien und mit
dem sinken der pfalz haben es im sommer
hin ist auch die debatte abgeflacht was
die pflege bonus angeht aus 1500 euro
wurden 1000 euro aus pflege wurde dann
altenpflege und ambulante pflege was
auch super wichtig sie haben es geld
auch verdient mittlerweile haben einige
auf den intensivstationen diesen bonus
bekommen überwiegend landeseigene häuser
also kliniken die dem land unterstehen
aber es gibt da in allen häusern auch in
den privaten häusern genug personal was
genau so hart gearbeitet hat und da ist
der pflege bonus der erste noch nicht
angekommen obwohl schon der zweite raum
steht und wie schon erwähnt ich als
leasing kraft also in keiner klinik
angestellt sondern um ein
zeitarbeitsunternehmen wenn sie so
völlig raus aus dieser bonusdebatte weil
die anforderung ist ja das eine klinik
eine bestimmte anzahl an corona
patienten über einen gewissen zeitraum
betreut haben muss und ja also ist
natürlich eine sache die die pflege
ziemlich spaltet also weil natürlich
also mir persönlich wäre lieber dass
sich die arbeitsbedingungen ändern klar
1500 euro kann wahrscheinlich jeder
gebrauchen
aber ja dieser bonus hat er dazu geführt
dass so die pflege sei er so spaltet
weil darum diskutiert wird man fühlt
sich natürlich nicht wertgeschätzt nicht
weil man die bonus nicht bekommen hat
aber wenn man beklatscht und bejubelt
wird und einige sachen versprochen
werden und wenn man dann nicht mehr
gebraucht wird wie letztes jahr im
sommer alles wieder weg ist wo man dann
ganz erstaunt im herbst gesagt hat wo
menschen brauchen pflegekräfte die
zweite welle kommt leider gut den sind
nicht erfüllt jetzt hat der junge wieder
zielgerichtet zwei themen aufgenommen
wir sagen muss erstens ist kontrolle der
pandemie strategie der bundesregierung
jetzt haben die zwei mal das gegenteil
behauptet und deswegen sage ich es jetzt
noch ein zweites mal die kontrolle über
die pandemie zu bekommen über die
infektionszahlen und die incidents
zahlen runter zu bringen ist strategie
der bundesregierung sonst hätten wir ja
wohl kaum
im übrigen vorgeschlagen das ist eine
bundes notbremse gibt um die regelungen
entsprechend auch umzusetzen und
durchzusetzen und sonst sehe ich hier
nicht schon seit vielen vielen wochen
und würde auf genau das hinweisen
nämlich was auf den intensivstationen
jeden tag passiert und deswegen bitte
ich einfach dass tatsächlich jetzt auch
mal zur kenntnis zu nehmen kann ich nur
darum bitten das zweite ist was die
situation in der pflege angeht
das wäre jetzt eine längere vortrag aber
die ausgrenzung der pflegekosten aus den
budgets aus den fallpauschalen die
größte veränderung seit über 20 jahren
haben wir vor dieser pandemie bereits
gemacht um das klare signal an die
krankenpflege in den krankenhäusern zu
senden ist kann nicht mehr zu lasten der
pflege gespart werden aber geregelt
alles was für pflege ausgegeben wird
wird eins zu eins refinanziert
tariferhöhung werden eins zu eins
refinanziert für die pflege in den
krankenhäusern personalbemessung
personal untergrenzen auf
intensivstationen aber auch an einer
station habe ich 1 geführt sich minister
verordnung weil die selbstverwaltung
zwischen krankenkassen und krankenhäuser
nicht in der lage war sie zu verhandeln
das erste mal seit jahrzehnten dass es
personal vorgaben für krankenhäuser gibt
vor der pandemie bereits eingeführt
unter den umständen der pandemie
zeitweise ausgesetzt
aber grundsätzlich übrigens verstärkt
seit dem ersten zweiter wieder in kraft
das zusammenführen des der ausbildung in
den pflegeberufen das abschaffung der
schulgelder das einführen einer
ausbildungsvergütung haben wir alles vor
der pandemie bereits begonnen die
stärkung der unterschiedlichen
fachrichtungen vor der pandemie begonnen
1 ist nur war und da hat der lange ja
recht wir haben auch teilweise im
politischen das gefühl wir würden aus
vollen rohren das problem adressieren
und vor ort dass bis jetzt eher das
gefühl da kommen tropfen auf dem heißen
stein
weil das eine entwicklung ist die über
viele viele jahre jahr in die falsche
richtung gegangen ist und jemand dann
nicht innerhalb von zwölf monaten in die
andere bringen kann und nicht 24 monate
aber ich lege auch da großen wert darauf
dass in der pflege in den letzten drei
jahren
krankenhäuser mehr verändert worden ist
als in vielen vielen jahren zuvor um den
beruf insgesamt attraktiver zu machen
und dazu gehört auch und da haben wir
lange und ich gestern noch kurz darüber
gesprochen dass ich zeitarbeit als etwas
was dinge abdecken soll sozusagen
spitzenlast durchaus akzeptieren kann
aber nicht unter der momentanen
gesamtbelastung in der pflege als
dauerlösung möchte und wird deswegen ja
auch die rahmenbedingungen verändert
haben dass tatsächlich fest angestellte
in manchen fragen tatsächlich andere
rahmenbedingungen haben das stimmt da
haben sie recht herr jung selber ein
grund weil zeitarbeit jedenfalls als die
lösung für pflegemangel aus meiner sicht
nur wenn überhaupt symptome bekämpft
aber nicht ursache erreichen möchte
ihnen insgesamt ihre beeindruckenden
schilderung danke ich kann sie ja
kürzlich ganz schlecht verstehen ich
möchte sie ich möchte mich bedanken für
ihre sehr eindrücklichen schilderung für
mich sehr beeindruckend also das möchte
ich mal vorweg geben und eine frage
folgt dann sind sie alle drei es gibt
ein viel diskutiertes thema migranten
google 19 erkrankungen schwere verläufe
intensivstation
da möchte ich ganz gerne gibt es
erfahrungen gibt es konkrete zahlen zu
diesem sachverhalt liga sie sagt mir mal
vor ein paar monaten das sei eine tabu
warum ist das so
und damit es da sparen wenn sie den
prioritäten könnten würden sie dann in
problembezirken manchmal auch prioritär
impfen lassen
also zuerst einmal ist das kein tabu nie
gewesen aus meiner sicht jedenfalls sich
anzuschauen welche bevölkerungsgruppen
ein besonders hohes risiko haben und
warum dieses risiko entsteht und das
risiko entsteht in teilen auch aus der
sozialen lage
das hat etwas zu tun mit
wohnverhältnissen es hat etwas zu tun
mit der möglichkeit überhaupt home
office machen zu können oder eben nicht
und es hat natürlich was damit zu tun ob
welche informationen wie jemanden
erreichen können da sind wir bei der
frage von sprachbarrieren
da sind wir bei der frage von
mediennutzung die unterschiedlich ist da
sind wir bei der frage von
unterschiedlichen kulturellen
hintergründen
das ist ja manchmal schon zwischen
katholiken und protestanten so dass die
frage wie die zusammenkünfte sind in
welcher größenordnung unterschiedlich
sind und es gibt auch schon unterschiede
in europa zwischen italien und
skandinavien in der frage bei welcher
art von zusammenkunft und
veranstaltungen ist welche
infektionsrisiken gibt und die sind
natürlich auch mit religiösen
hintergrund verboten deswegen bin ich
übrigens den islamischen
glaubensgemeinschaften sehr dankbar dass
sie beim thema jetzt fastenbrechen sehr
darum gebeten und dafür geworben haben
so schwer das feld das eben
weitestgehend in kleinstgruppen wenn
überhaupt oder wenn's geht digital
digital zu machen
deswegen muss man natürlich darüber wie
man kann probleme nur adressieren wenn
man sie bespricht dabei schon immer von
überzeugt was wir nicht können weil sie
woran wollen sie denn erkennen ob jemand
einen migrationshintergrund hat also
dass man das irgendwie nachnamen erkennt
ist schon lange nicht mehr so gott sei
dank teilweise zehn fünfter generation
in deutschland leben
denn wenn man vielleicht die vermutung
hätte aufgrund eines nachnamen völliger
quatsch
also wie wollen sie auf einer
intensivstation diese statistik führen
die manche einfordern die ist aus meiner
sicht wenn man sie überhaupt schön
wollte da kann man schon darüber
streiten so gar nicht so leicht zu
führen weil was soll was soll das
kriterium für diese frage sein
wichtig ist einfach miteinander zu sehen
wo sind infektionsrisiken größer warum
sind sie größer hat das was mit sozialer
lage zu tun mit kulturellen
zusammenhängen religiösen zusammenhängen
zu tun gibt es andere gründe und darauf
reagieren wir müssen wir reagieren
wollen wir reagieren das gilt auch für
die impfkampagne habe ich deutschland
ausgeführt die genau auf diese
unterschiedlichen gruppen adressieren
wird und soll und auch schon tut
und daneben natürlich auch in den
entsprechenden stadtteilen aber es ist
ja auch schon so es wird immer so es ist
wie mit drive ins oder oder supermarkt
wieder alle wieder jetzt auch im
supermarkt impfen geht doch alles wie
man das land das im supermarkt impfen
will keinem supermarkt impfen dann muss
man da ärzte hinstellen muss meine
station aufbauen kann man im supermarkt
impfen kann jedes bundesland morgen
machen was man nicht fordern kann man
machen
das gleiche gilt für impfen in
stadtteilen kann man machen ist alles
möglich einige machen es auch schon köln
soweit ich weiß ja diese zahlen sind
liegen uns nicht vor wir wissen das
nicht aber was wir natürlich wissen und
das ist ja ein alt bekanntes wissen wir
auch gerade erst im robert-koch-institut
dazu wieder nur publikationen verfasst
natürlich ist es so dass menschen in
bestimmten lagen bildungsferne schichten
menschen die einkommen schwächer sind
und dass wir wissen dass diese menschen
insgesamt ein größeres risiko haben
infiziert zu werden krank zu werden wir
wissen ja dass in deutschland auch
eigentlich von der lage der sozialen
lage und dem bildungsstand zwischen
männern innerhalb unseres kleinen landes
zehn jahre unterschiedliche
lebenserwartung ist je nachdem wo sie
leben und welchen umständen leben das
heißt also die umstände in denen
menschen leben die verhältnisse wie sie
arbeiten zb das sind die entscheidenden
risikofaktoren die dazu führen dass
menschen ein höheres risiko haben
infiziert zu werden oder nicht das ist
die frage der wir uns immer stellen
müssen und da ist genau der
entscheidende punkt dass da natürlich
lokal vor ort ganz genau die bestimmten
gruppierungen besucht werden informiert
werden und aufgeklärt werden und
natürlich müssen arbeitgeber auch ihren
mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
ausgegeben dass sich vor bestimmten
infektionen schützen und dann ist es
klar dass bestimmte arbeit prekäre
arbeitsverhältnisse gibt wo das
schwieriger ist und dort findet man eben
bestimmte gruppierungen häufiger
überrepräsentiert also in der welt und
das ist aber ein altes bekanntes wissen
aber ich kann ihnen nicht die zahl nicht
wir kennen keine zahlen darüber wie sich
das momentan darstellt auf den
intensivstationen liegen keine vor also
für mich auch schwierig zu sagen welche
patientengruppe sage jetzt mal da liegt
bei für mich liegt vorrangig ein mensch
da der meine hilfe benötigt und die
bekommt er auch ich könnte mir
vielleicht vorstellen dass wenn es dann
zum beispiel menschen mit
migrationshintergrund trifft die boni
teilweise in der köln mit großfamilien
in kleinen wohnungen daran für uns
vielleicht liegen aber wir wissen sind
wir besser informiert
aber ich kann auch kein trend irgendwie
groß erkennen auf den intensivstationen
welche personengruppen es trifft genau
die frage nach dem alter es gibt mal
phasen werden letztens eine schwangere
unter 30 jahre
28 war die genau die war so schwer krank
die musste quasi intubiert und offenbau
gedreht werden mussten das baby holen
vorher in den 25.10 woche aber es gibt
halt auch dann wieder phasen wo wieder
vermehrt ältere sind also eine patientin
differenzierung kann man findet gar
nicht so treffen ob sie es im
migrationshintergrund haben oder nicht
oder nein beantworten warum ist ein
tabus oder beziehungsweise verständlich
sorge dass man möglicherweise
also ich möchte dazu noch mal sagen das
ist eine private unterhaltung war die in
keinster weise sich mit dem thema
intensiv beschäftigte sondern es waren
ausführungen die mit einem kollegen
kreis und im kreis von bekannten
getroffen wurde
wichtig ist und das ist der
entscheidende punkt wichtig ist dass wir
aufklären wer sich infiziert hat dass
wir die orte und die verhaltensweisen
klären wie man sich schützt und wir
schritt wir stecken uns da an wo viele
menschen auf engem raum zusammen sind
und zwar insbesondere in innenräumen
das heißt also es gibt bestimmte
situationen wo die chance ist nicht
anzustecken größer als in anderen und
wir müssen unabhängig davon welche
gruppierung es ist unabhängig davon
welche sprachlichen internet man hat
müssen wir allen menschen klar machen wo
sie ein hohes infektionsrisiko haben und
wo dieses infektionsrisiko wie man das
eben unterbinden kann und das gleiche
gilt natürlich auch dafür wenn es um die
impfung liegt natürlich müssen wir auch
allen menschen eine impfung anbieten und
ein impfangebot machen auch das eben
unabhängig von der sozialen lage das ist
ja der entscheidende punkt aber dann
muss man das eben auch tun
und das muss man in erster linie tun
indem man lokal vor ort die angebote an
bietet das ist ja eine aufgabe die in
den kommunen insbesondere von den
kommunen erledigt werden müssen und die
die nutzung die die impfung in
bestimmten sozialen brennpunkten oder
wie immer man das nennen
das ist die verantwortung des landes und
der entsprechenden kommunen das zu tun
und wenn genügend ihm stoffe da sind
dann möge es bitte dafür gesorgt wenn
das so viele menschen wie möglich dann
auch so schnell wie möglich geimpft
werden
und ich kann nur hoffen dass diese
impfbereitschaft auch so hoch bleibt wie
sie jetzt ist denn sie ist eben der weg
aus dieser panini herr kollege
philipp menn wdr ich habe trotzdem noch
mal eine nachfrage bei dem thema weil es
ja so ist das der kanzlerkandidat der
cdu csu gestern dieses thema aufgeworfen
hat und der kanzlerkandidat der spd dass
heute das heißt ich hatte gedacht daraus
entwickelt sich dann auch so einen
arbeitsauftrag an sie herr sparen denn
sie sagen jetzt ist es sache der
kommunen vielleicht sache der länder in
sozialen brennpunkten stärker zu impfen
das sind dabei teilweise ganze
stadtteile die 600 oder 700 studenten
haben und weiter soweit ich mich richtig
erinnere gab es ja auch so etwas wie die
ring impfung dazu wurden ja auch vom
bund spezielle kontingente für
bundesländer bzw landkreise zur
verfügung gestellt das wäre ja auch ein
modell man könnte ja auch jetzt oder sie
können ja auch sagen dass sie besonderen
wert darauf legen dass da wo es eben
diese brennpunkte und diese sehr hohe
incidents gibt die auch gefahren für
andere stadt hat er damit sich bringt
dass der bund da eben jetzt in die
bresche springt und sagt weil unsere
kanzlerkandidat und parteichefs wollen
stellen wir da jetzt spezielle
kontingente zur verfügung wo er nämlich
die herren sie haben sie auch damals
irgendwo vorgenommen nie ja das also wir
schicken doch jede woche kontingente in
die länder 2,25 millionen dosen gehen
jede woche in die länder zu den
impfzentren und ich finde da muss jetzt
ein bisschen aufpassen dass wir nicht so
eine debatte führen dass wird das alles
nicht längst stattfinden
also es ist doch das was die
bürgermeister die landräte die
landesregierung schon längst machen
wie gesagt nach allem was ich weiß in
köln dieser tage in bestimmten
stadtteilen genau das was sie sagen eben
in hoch incidents regionen sozusagen
verstärkt zu impfen die impfdosen können
ja dafür eingesetzt werden und werden es
auch vor ort und ich finde wir müssen
ein bisschen aufpassen dass sich der
eindruck entsteht als wäre das jetzt
irgendwie so ein thema das irgendwie
letzte woche plötzlich über uns gekommen
ist aber noch nie vorher einer darüber
nachgedacht hat natürlich und natürlich
machen wir da wo wir
informationskampagnen machen da wo wir
gespräche führen wir haben wir haben
beim integrationsgipfel über dieses
thema geredet
man kann bei anderen runden darüber
reden ich habe gerade gesagt ich werde
auch noch einmal das gespräch suche mit
einigen gesellschaftlichen gruppen aber
im städte- und gemeindetag und an den
verbänden kommunalen spitzenverbänden
darüber gesprochen wo wir
rahmenbedingungen des bundes verändern
können und die dinge leichter zu machen
oder zu informieren machen wir das auch
aber die konkrete entscheidung in einer
stadt in einem landkreis in einen
stadtteil zu gehen
die kann tatsächlich und das finde ich
übrigens auch vernünftig in der
föderalen ordnung nicht aus berlin
heraus getroffen werden sondern vor ort
und so wie ich das wahrnehmen wird diese
entscheidung jeden tag getroffen
wir sollten jetzt echt nicht so tun als
wird das alles nicht stattfinden also
das ist unnötig dass die beiden
spitzenpolitiker diese frage aufgeworfen
haben
das ist jetzt wieder ihre nicht meine
schlussfolgerung nein es ist ein thema
das man ich habe es ja selber in der
dann ja auch internen runde man kann ja
neuerdings nix mehr sagen wenn mehr als
zwei dabei sind was dann irgendwo nicht
doch steht ist ja alles okay aber
natürlich diskutieren wir darüber
natürlich ist es richtig dass das
darüber gesprochen und sich verhalten
wird
genauso richtig ist es aber ich bin sehr
sicher dass haben sowohl herr
ministerpräsident laschet wie er
minister scholz gemeint dass das eine
debatte ist die jetzt auch nicht völlig
neu ist ich habe jetzt noch drei
kollegen auf der liste danach können wir
noch gerne beenden möchte schließt schon
acht stunden hier die erste letzte die
vorletzte frage hat er inkl
dann gehen wir doch schon der
kolleginnen und kollegen frage an herrn
spahn
es geht um den europäischen impfpass ich
hätte ganz gern gewusst ob sie dafür
sind dass das für alle impfstoffe gilt
also dieser pass ausgestellt wird oder
nur für die die in der eu oder von der
ema zugelassen werden weil sie im stoffe
wie sputnik der einen einzelnen eu
ländern eingesetzt werden von der iba
noch nicht zugelassen sind nur von der
eu zugelassen werden wir zu kurz
gesprungen aber erstmal nur impfstoffe
über die wir wissen also ich möchte
schon wissen ob auch andere impfstoffe
gleich gut nicht zu 100 prozent aber
gleich gut vergleichbar gut infektionen
vermeiden oder nichtsein unterschied ob
das vermeiden von infektionen zu 70 80
prozent gelingt oder zur 40
und man hört ja sehr unterschiedlich ist
auch aus dem beispiel viele aus der
ferne betrachtet wo ja auch viele andere
impfstoffe zum einsatz gekommen sind ob
das dann tatsächlich auch die
übertragung ähnlich stark verringert das
weiß ich nicht das müssen wir einfach
das wenig weil wir die daten nicht haben
das würde ich nicht sagen das per se
eu-zulassung voraussetzung ist aber
zumindest mal eine bewertung aufgrund
von studiendaten ob dieser eben stoff
vergleichbar gut auch infektionen
vermeiden hilft die hätte ich schon
gerne um den entsprechend
gleichzustellen
derzeit ist das heißt es dann für die
nutzung dieses engpasses in deutschland
so lange wir das nicht gewährleistet ist
nutzt er das bei der einreise nach
deutschland erstmal nichts
die gespräche war übrigens auch gestern
thema wie auch beim austausch mit meinem
chinesischen amtskollegen letzte woche
müssen wir einfach natürlich miteinander
reden darüber was die frage der
anerkenntnis ist von ausweisen
ob digital oder analog wir werden
übrigens international sehr stark dafür
auch den papiernen papieren dem ausweis
aus papier weiterhin zu akzeptieren weil
es einfach auch länder geben wird die
gar keine chance haben
digitale impfausweise gleich schon
auszustellen
und das wäre enorme einschränkungen
daneben auch von freiheiten auf der welt
deswegen den digitalen mvhs weiß oder
impfausweise generell mit impfstoffen wo
man vorher jedenfalls mal bilateral in
diesem fall meine ich mit bilateral
europäische union mit den anderen
ländern darüber gesprochen hat für
welche impfstoffe man das eben gleich
fertig auch gleichwertig auch so
handhaben kann die nase deutsche welle
an herrn villa eine frage ich möchte
nochmal zur situation in asien zurück
kommen man weiß ja inzwischen auch dass
die variante in den nachbarländern von
indien angekommen ist mit welchen blick
schauen sie auf die situation da wenn
man sich überlegt bangladesch oder nepal
und damit direkt die nächste große krise
naja wir schauen uns hier werden wir
eine eine abteilung ein zentrum für
internationalen gesundheitsschutz
dieses zentrum schaut sich länder
konsequent an und zwar viele länder der
welt
manche natürlich zu bestimmten zeiten
intensiver als andere
wir beobachten dass wir sind da einen
austausch mit vielen kollegen und
kollegen direkt aus den ländern und und
ich will noch mal sagen ist unabhängig
von dieser variante die jetzt wieder
auch so ein bisschen holzschnittartig so
als als neue bedrohung gesehen wird
diese pandemie ist gerade auf einem
neuen höhepunkt also weltweit wenn so
viele fälle pro tag gemeldet wie noch
nie zuvor
also wir sind ja mitten in dieser
pandemie drin
und selbst in ländern wie zb indien wo
teilweise davon auch gesprochen wurde
dass in den eventuell schon so was wie
eine hohe durch solche hätte also dass
zum beispiel sehr viele menschen schon
mal eigentlich durch gewesen wären
minister sparen sagt sie ihm eine der
jüngsten
population weltweit dass das da sie
schon viele ihn nun wären das ist
natürlich nicht so sondern es gibt da
ganz schöne daten mit mit einem
bestimmten servus wales hat man dann
durchgeführt eine sehr hohe prävalenz
und da kommt man vielleicht auf 20 24
prozent was eine enorme durch solchen
ist aber dass er heißt eben das 80 75
prozent nicht durch sorgt also ich mir
wäre es einfach wichtig dass das dass
alle verstehen weil ich nehme sie immer
wieder war dass es wird immer wieder auf
einen zeitpunkt geguckt und einem land
geschaut diese pandemie die wird noch
lange auf dieser erde unterwegs sein
sie kann auch eben immer wieder zu uns
zurück kommen solange wir nicht genügend
geimpft haben also darum ist es wichtig
dass wir das ausland mit im blick haben
aber für unsere situation hier ist es
wichtig dass wir das alle bitte ihr
angebot so schnell wie möglich war
nehmen und meiner mobilität dass es ein
aspekt den ich auch immer wieder
ansprechen mobilität ist eben ein punkt
wenn man in solche gebiete reist dann
erhält man nicht die chance dass man
eine infektion mit nach hause bringt
also insofern wird uns das noch
mindestens die vero geht davon aus also
dass das team mit dem ich ziemlich eng
in kontakt bin dort wir gehen davon aus
dass sie bis ende 2022 noch voll in der
pandemie sein werden und so lange wird
dieses virus auch nicht unter kontrolle
sein und dann hoffen wir dass möglichst
viele länder die chance haben zu impfen
aber das eben verflucht auch mal auch
alle leute das impfangebot annehmen weil
sonst helfen die impfungen auch nichts
ja es ist wickelt das ist der
entscheidende punkt dass mensch das
ebenfalls gebot annehmen und dafür
sollten wir so auch in unserem eigenen
land und der a2 recorder wenn ich da
finale zu ende der pressekonferenz wir
haben erstens gestern zum ersten mal
mehr als ein prozent der bevölkerung an
einem tag geimpft und zweiter rekord zum
ersten mal über eine million
informierten gestern 1,1 millionen
impfungen knapp damit sind 25,9 prozent
der deutschen mindestens einmal geimpft
und 7,5 prozent
haben eine zweite impfung die arzt darum
gestern 730.000 impfungen durchgeführt
die impfzentren 360.000 aber zum ersten
mal über ein prozent der bevölkerung an
ein und zwar deutlich über ein prozent
ein prozent werden 830.000 impfungen
knapp 1,1 millionen impfungen zeigt wie
stark wir an geschwindigkeit gewonnen
haben es reicht noch nicht um die grund
immunität für die bevölkerung insgesamt
zu haben aber jede impfung ist schutz
für jemanden und das finde ich ist jetzt
noch mal eine gute nachfrage geht an den
kollegen
sowas habe ich vom portal watson
ersparen meine frage ist nur wird er
wieder hat es wieder angesprochen das
problem wir haben jetzt schon
erschreckend viele fälle von menschen
die monate nach einem milden verlauf
sehr sehr schwere einschränkungen haben
darunter leiden und die studienlage
deutet auf ein besonders hohes risiko
bei jungen frauen hin was will das
bundesgesundheitsministerium tun um
diesen menschen in der rehabilitation in
bei der rückkehr zu einem möglichst
beschwerdefreies leben helfen zuerst
einmal auch in absprache mit dem
forschungsministerium und federführer
des forschungsministeriums forschung
rund um longo witt und das phänomen das
zweite ist wie sie angesprochen haben
reha angebote die es ja auch schon gibt
die sich entwickelt haben ich habe
selbst schon entsprechende realen
angebot besucht entsprechend zu
unterstützen bestmöglich zu schauen ob
für den rahmenbedingungen was verändern
müssen damit sie weiter auch erhalten
bleiben sich ausbauen können und einfach
soviel wissen wie es geht
an zu sammeln und möglich zu machen
über dieses erkrankungsbild und vor
allem auch über therapieoptionen und
reha optionen also wir haben das im
beständigen blick und sind dazu nicht
nur im engen austausch sondern auch in
kooperation mit dem
forschungsministerium sozusagen was
forschung angeht aber eben auch
versorgung angeht das gut miteinander
wenn dann dazu vernetzen die wahrheit
ist natürlich über longo wird der
definitionen haben wir maximal im moment
zwölf monate wissen so zu sagen ob
deutlich viele jahre möglicherweise ist
belastung gibt oder nicht das werden wir
leider dann ja erst über die zeit sehen
die rückfrage meines wissens haben sich
deutsche meister 20 das erste mal
ministerium aus darauf hingewiesen auf
das problem gibt es das seither aus
ihrer sicht hätten wir das nicht schon
neue erkenntnisse dass man sagen kann
hat wirklich entscheidendes dazu gelernt
zum longo wird also ich kann das jetzt
stante pede nicht sagen aber wir können
immer schauen uns einmal eine lernkurve
forscher oder versorgern mitbringen ja
es gibt eine menge von informationen
aber die sind eben immer noch nicht so
aussagefähig dass man das syndrom
wirklich klar bekennen und die
langzeitfolgen hat es gibt ein großes
konsortium natürlich auch in deutschland
von den universitäts netzwerken klingen
da ist das ag selber auch beteiligt und
ich denke dass in kürze auch dazu dann
erste ergebnisse kommen aber ich will
noch mal folgendes sagen das ist dass
das ist das interesse was alle haben die
da oben sitzen wir müssen in sidenten
runter kriegen weniger menschen sich
anstecken desto weniger gelungen cockpit
haben wir und desto weniger menschen
werden im krankenhaus sein
also bitte haben sie diesen präventiven
gedanken im kopf
die einschränkung von kontakten ist nach
wie vor der effizienteste weg
natürlich werden wir dann forschen und
natürlich werden wir neue
therapieoptionen haben aber es will
davon keiner von uns möglichst viele
fälle haben um daran forschen zu können
wir wollen infektionen vermeiden
das ist denke ich der hauptgrund warum
wir hier seit vielen wochen immer wieder
darauf hinweisen dass diese krankheit
nicht zu unterschätzen ist und dann
haben wir noch mal ein impfstoff und
dann sind wir in deutschland in wenigen
monaten in einer guten lage aber viele
länder auf der welt sind in dieser guten
lagert nicht
und dann geht es auch ja
damit sind wir am ende der
pressekonferenz danke für die geduldig
danken dass er lange schön dank ich
danke ihnen und möchte mich bei ihnen
entschuldigen die länder nicht
rangekommen sind insbesondere unter